[Applaudissements]
ok attention j'ai de tahiti des parents
et carlos
d'après la formule chemise basket comme
on le voudrait on ne rigolait pas parce
que
je n'aime pas les pions en plus
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission ou avec nous ce soir
la belle-soeur du charme à ben laden
des connards
alain chabat y opposerons michaël youn
vincent et benjamin elena lenina
djamel bouras
mam bridging
benjamin violée
victime d'un pédophile il raconte dans
un livre bouleversant
me chabert
et le blind test de jean cau cidre est
j'accueille maintenant car même ben
laden
[Musique]
bonsoir
alors carmen been made in comme vous
dites vous êtes la belle-soeur donc
d'oussama ben laden
pourquoi avoir pris been la dinepa ben
laden c'est comme ça que le compère de
maisons pour l'écrivaine et certains
frères l'ont changé à sa mort j'aime
bien carmen ben laden oui comment
réagissent les gens à votre à votre nom
hier en venant à paris le 2 nîmes n'a
raté oui à regarder sur son computer
aller est allé derrière train de
téléphoner et pour finir une malaise
s'est passé malgré que je ne passe
poursuit ce qui facilite quand même
d'avoir le passeport 6 avec le nom ben
laden ce n'est pas tout à fait la même
chose que d'avoir un passeport saoudien
avec j'ai perdu beaucoup d'amis après le
11 septembre
je crois que c'était je pense que ce
n'est pas vraiment des amis alors vous
apparteniez à une famille des plus
prestigieuses d'arabie saoudite
aujourd'hui ben laden vous êtes un petit
peu devenu une sorte de deux parias non
oui aussi
ouais entre autres du difficile je crois
qu'elle pour mes fils est très très
difficile
c'est très difficile parce que c'est
nous réalisons que c'est un nom auquel
on peut pas s'échapper
c'est à dire et changer le nom ne
changerait rien changerait rien on dira
toujours même j'ai vraiment conscience
que même s'il de masse des jeunes filles
si elles se marient et prennent le nom
de leur mari
on dirait toujours et uc72 vettel mais
l'aîné
alors votre fille ou afin était accusé
d'avoir été prévenu du 11 septembre et
d'avoir retardé son retour à new york où
elle vivait alors que votre fille en
fête de rentrée le 15 à new york qu'elle
n'a pas retardé son départ à cause du 11
septembre n'a pas été prévenus à
l'avancé ni à genève pour l'été et
elle était rentrée pour les vacances
ouais alors quand vous apprenez
l'attentât du world trade center
vous êtes dans votre voiture vous allez
de lausanne à genève avec votre fille
wafa justement un ami vous appelle de
new york après l'impact dans la première
tour du world trade center et avant
l'impact du deuxième avion tout de suite
vous pensez que si nous sommes
abdelhaleem voix de nos frères je me
souviens très bien la première quand il
m'a dit attends il ya un autre avion et
mon dieu il rentre dans un dans la
second tour et moi ma première réaction
c'était mon dieu leur nom va être
partout dans les journaux je crois
pensez vous pas mal j'ai pas pensé j'ai
diminué leur nom va être partout dans
les journaux alors j'ai vraiment
inquiète alors quand même ben laden vous
publié chez michel lafon le voile
déchirée ou vous racontez votre histoire
alors votre mariage avec l'un des frères
donc d'oussama ben laden
les neuf ans que vous avez passé en
arabie saoudite dans le clan ben laden
vos rencontres avec votre beau-frère
oussama est votre combat pour fuir tout
ça avec vous trois filles alors on va
prendre les choses par le par le
commencement
votre mère donc est issu de
l'aristocratie iranienne elle avait mis
sa famille devant le fait accompli en
fait en épousant secrètement à paris
monsieur dufour citoyens suisses se
rencontrer à lausanne pendant ses études
évitez quoi votre père homme d'affaires
alors vos parents se sont séparés quand
vous étiez très jeunes avaient eu plus
aucun contact avec votre père votre
maire a pris soin de le rendre ça tout à
fait étanche quoi voilà alors votre
maire elle est née musulmane n'était pas
très pratiquante un nom le jeu suit pas
le ramadan
le prix n'est pas très souvent quand je
suis arrivé en arabie saoudite je sais
toujours pas prier je ne remets pas
prier allah au printemps 1973
vous êtes agenaise donc vous vivez à
l'époque avec votre mère est
malheureusement plus votre père il ya
beaucoup de touristes saoudiens qui
viennent à un genève pour l'été vous
devez partir en vacances en iran dans la
famille de votre mère et votre mère sous
loue un étage de sa maison donc quand
vous n'êtes pas là aux frères d'oussama
ben laden qui s'appelle yeslam mène la
laine donc et puis vous tombe follement
amoureuse de lui
voilà vous partez suivre ensemble vos
études aux usa et aux usa vous découvrez
l'importance de la famille ben laden
c'est dire que en arrivant là bas y'a
des gens l'université qui vous ont dit
mais c'est des gens extrêmement puissant
extrêmement important oui j'ai rencontré
un étudiant saoudien qui était dans ma
classe parler qui est qui et diamé
avec l'anem le cheikh hamad était
quelqu'un de tout ce qui était très
respectée on habite à auditer et qu'il
avait beaucoup aidé c'est là où j'ai
réalisé 1 vous savez à l'époque personne
ne parlait de y'avait pas encore eu le
choc pétrolier dans une arabie saoudite
qui n'est pas l'arabie saoudite actuelle
et il était plutôt prestigieux aux yeux
des saoudiens alors le mariage a lieu en
arabie saoudite vous auriez préféré
genève mais vous savez pas vous avez pas
gain de cause
et là on arrive on vous découvrez la
bahia c'est à dire qu'on vous habille de
la bahia alors vous vous en rendez pas
compte mais vous regardez votre soeur
salomé et vous découvrez qu'en fait on
va même pas ses yeux quoique c'est
complètement voyez rien de traiter cet
été j'avais pris le voile à la manière
mais je l'avais je l'avais fait à genève
et c'était vraiment très épais très
opaque
oui c'est le voyais c'était au début
pour moi c'était quelque chose d'amusant
c'était quelque chose vous savez comme
moi je porte le voile ce qu'est ce
qu'ils puissent quand je suis arrivé ce
que je fais ça m'avait dit qu'il n'y
avait rien pas de théâtre pas de deux
deux librairies pas de cinéma pas de
restaurant et de l'entente vous dis dans
mon cas il n'ya pas mais vous l'imaginez
pas c'est quand vous êtes là ce que vous
imaginez qu est-ce que c'est vraiment
non il n'y a vraiment rien rien là vous
découvrez donc la vie des femmes en
arabie saoudite évidemment confinées à
la maison ne devant pas être vu par des
hommes extérieurs à la famille et même
quand vous allez dans le jardin chez
vous les employés s'en vont pour pas
vous voir toi bien sur mer avait un
chauffeur parce que bien sûr les femmes
ne conduisait pas un avis aux audits qui
l'amenait d'une maison à l'autre et le
chauffeur n'avait jamais vu le visage de
ma mère
alors que vous en faites après quelques
temps le chauffeur voit votre visage
bien plus tard tout à fait alors voilà
donc une drôle de vie avec les journaux
qui arrive caviardé avec des traits
noirs à cause de son sujet pour la
première fois que je n'aime pas les
journaux dont là bas tout est pêché à la
promenade c'est un péché la musique
c'est un péché la danse c'est un péché
l'art heureusement votre mari vous
traite pas comme ses frères traitent
leurs femmes
et effectivement vous vous participez à
l'époque à un semblant de modernisation
en arabie saoudite on allait encore dans
les supermarchés à voile et tout et je
me suis toujours demandée par exemple
comment et parce que je sortais du
supermarché mon chauffeur savez ils
venaient exactement se mettre à côté de
moi et j'étais sous la voie alléchant
version des faits c'était vraiment
surprenant c'est sûr que non non ça
c'était avant la chute du chah d'iran et
l'arrivée de commenee donc à téhéran
après il ya eu un véritable retour en
arrière si on vous dit que les femmes
ont été obligées de porter non seulement
des abayas mais des bas noirs sous les
abayas pourquoi qu'on voit un petit bout
de leur cher ce qui était obligatoire
c'est-à-dire en dehors de c'était
l'émeute à voir la police religieuse
et où il avait été peut-être une année
plutôt un peu plus laxistes c'est à dire
que il nous faisait pas sortir des
magasins au moment des prières et j'ai
senti un certain laxisme à ce moment là
de nouveau on nous faisait ressortir des
magasins les magasins étaient fermés on
devait remplir les magasins devaient
être fermés les gens veulent et encore
maintenant en arabie saoudite à l'heure
de la prière les magasins sont fermés
les gens sortent et en général vous
savez où vous attendez dans les voitures
en tout cas moi j'attendais dans la
voiture avec mon chauffeur jusqu'à un
quart d'heure jusqu'à que la prière
c'est terminé je retournais dans le
magasin alors à ce moment là vous
découvrez que vos filles subissent des
influences néfastes présent vous
découvrez que sur un cahier
on leur a fait écrire je hais les juifs
j'aime la palestine alors vous vous êtes
choqués évidemment partir à l'école à
l'école s'était très bien vous allez à
l'école et je leur ai demandé s'ils mais
qui produit des cours de géographie
passera par et 7 ans il m'a dit nono
noah redonne les cours déjà fier dix ans
alors je dis si j'appelle ma fille et je
lui demande de montrer sur la carte
la palestine est ce qu'elle sera aussi
je me dis non non et non je vous dis à
11 ans dont selon lui apprenez à lire
quelque chose qu'elle n'arrivait même
pas placer sur la carte veut donc j'ai
dit voilà la directrice de l'école qui
vous dit vous n'y comprenez rien toute
façon vous êtes une étrangère et cette
phrase terrible
elle vous dit est ce que votre mari est
au courant de votre démarche c'est à
dire que ça n'avait tout argument avec
moi parce que j'ai je mairie et comme on
dit j'ai essayé de lui expliquer que je
ne voulais pas que mes filles haïssent
quelqu'un sur la base de leur religion
de et je lui ai même dit si un jour je
perds la rigueur accepter que ma fille
ait quelqu'un mais je voudrais que les
au moins une bonne raison et jeu est là
elle me dit à court d'arguments elle se
retourne vers moi elle me regarde comme
ça elle dit est ce que votre mari est
courant ici et j'étais furieuse
je vais je lui ai dit écoutez mon mari
va vous téléphoner je suis rentré à la
maison et j'ai dit à la somme si tu
appelles pas cette personne tout je ne
resterai pas et c'est exact et les fans
et vous finissez par partir de là bas en
85 vous installer en suisse donc votre
marié vous le sentez un petit peu de
s'éloigner de s'éloigner de vous à ce
moment là et vous découvrez qui ne vous
trompe un soir où balader dans jeunet
avec votre voiture et vous voyez sortie
avec ça avec sa secrétaire de son bureau
oui je crois que ça peut arriver ça mais
c'est sa réaction plus tard c'est à dire
que sa réaction m'a fait penser beaucoup
plus à une réaction d'un homme saoudien
qui s'était très normal hu alors vous
vous êtes plus jamais retournés en
arabie saoudite depuis carmen pas parce
que comme votre mari vous a accusé
d'adultère
la macif c'est passible de la peine de
mort je sais qu'en arabie saudite et ça
je le sais il n'a pas besoin de moi pour
divorcer la boe alors j'assume qui m'a
accusée d'adultère
vous êtes quoi aujourd'hui j'ai une
console et menteur qui était
je suis ce qu'on appelle en suisse en
mesure provisoire à dire que le juge me
donne
pour subvenir à mes besoins pas beaucoup
non non par rapport à ceux qui gagnent
sans pilote s'est pas beaucoup non
exactement
alors votre mari a beaucoup d'argent il
a quand même énormément de sociétés
offshore vous dites 75 et c'est
quelqu'un qui est quand même lié au
commerce international aux flux
financiers internationaux d'une façon
tout un petit peu opaque il a d'ailleurs
tenté de faire interdire en suisse un
livre s'appelle la vérité interdite de
dasquié brizard qu'on a reçu ici l'année
dernière
et puis le juge vendre une baie café
perquisitionné sa villa cannoise avec la
bergerie sur une enquête donc de
blanchiment blanchiment d'argent
est ce que vous pensez qu'à travers ces
circuits financiers un petit peu opaque
donc la famille ben laden et votre mari
entre autres continuent à soutenir
financièrement oussama ben laden je
pense qu'il ya énormément de gens en
arabie saoudite qui soutient tous les
causes islamistes je ne pense pas vous
savez je ne suis pas en train de dire
que si si oussama ou quelqu'un comme
oussama vient dire j'ai besoin d'argent
pour faire sauter une ambassade
on va lui donner de l'argent mais s'il
vient mais ils disent vous savez je vais
faire trois ou quatre modèles ça parce
que si vous la vallée le déni on ne va
pas hésiter à lui ne doit pas regarder
ce qui fait du pognon je vous dis dans
votre bouquin qu'il est très très proche
le d'abdallah qui est le prince héritier
d'arabie saoudite c'est une chose que
j'ai un que mon mari me l'a dit je me
souviens très bien mais je ne dis pas
que toute la famille royale le soutien
mais je pense que comme il y à des
membres de la famille royale qui qui qui
sont tout à fait d'accord avec eux avec
oussama
du reste vous savez donc pour beaucoup
d'arabes j'ai eu l'occasion de parler
ils disent qu'ils étaient la preuve qu
sa main a été impliqué dans ces
attentats n'existe pas et quand il parle
de cette base là et 10 secondes
et les occidentaux l'accusent centre
mais la revendiquer quand même ils
disent que d'après j'ai eu une
conversation justement avec quelqu'un
qui m'a dit ah non mais vous vécu ces
avec la technologie moderne on peut on
peut faire dire n'importe quoi sur cet
argent il est transmis comment vous
pensez si c'est pas par des banques sans
liquide non bien sûr vous savez moi à
coacher en arabie saoudite ou dans les
pays du moyen-orient tout se passe les
gens utilisent beaucoup de cash
il n'y a pas de traces à l'époque je
n'ai jamais eu des carnets de chèques en
arabie saudite je n'ai jamais eu de
winne de diabète et de l'argent oui
j'avais est ce que vous croyez que ça
m'a ben laden est toujours en vie je
suis persuadé qu'il est en vie parce que
je pense que c'est quelque chose était
arrivée à ossama la famille le ferai
savoir oui pour faire baisser la
pression qu'ils auront ce qu'ils ont sur
eux pour être un peu plus tranquille
alors maintenant la question à 25
millions de dollars
ça va et si jamais savait et on peut se
partager le pognon viléo je ne sais pas
il peut être partout ouais on arrondit
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils étaient au
pakistan ou en afghanistan dans les
zones tribales à la frontière entre
pakistan et en afghanistan
aucune idée sinon 25 millions de dollars
voilà vous raconter tout ça donc dans un
bouquin qui s'appelle le voile déchirée
vous rencontrez évidemment aussi vous
vous rencontre avec oussama ben laden
alors il ya extraordinaire un jour vous
êtes athée y est je crois il fait super
chaud
et puis moi ici contrairement à ici
voulu qu'on baisse la clim
s'il vous plaît si on peut baisser un
petit peu la clim parce que c'est vrai
que c'est pas le climat de l'arabie
saoudite ce soir donc un jour des
matériels il fait très chaud on vous
voyez là femmes d'oussama ben laden qui
nourrit leurs enfants à la petite
cuillère avec de l'eau avec de l'eau
alors vous dites pourquoi pas mais bon
j'ai offert bon du moment elle la refuse
et je ne comprenais pas et je me
rappelle je dire ma belle mère mais cet
enfant restait déshydraté pourquoi il
lui donne pas le biberon et au début
j'ai naïvement je croyais que je lui dis
mais mon biberon est stabilisée et et
les dinos amaro fils que nous sommes à
voulait pas quoique l'enfant et du
caoutchouc dans la bouche dans la pièce
ouais et j'ai fait appeler il ya
seulement dix ans écoutent va parler
avec ton père parce que cet enfant va
céder et traite des et raté les mains et
il est revenu en me disant non ils
refusent catégoriquement
mais pourquoi diable le caoutchouc sais
pas c'est peut être le cas où tu peux
pas être interdit par le coran puisque
ce n'est pas du temps de mahomet le cas
où tu es moi je ne sais pas si je
comprenais pas non plus jugé ces thèmes
qui n'ont jamais refuse que son bien
son fils prend
le biberon alors en descendant jeu cet
incident m'a marqué parce que c'était
aux chemins
c'est cet incident on m'a marqué parce
que pour la première fois j'ai réalisé
le poids de la parole d'un homme même
s'il n'était pas dans la pièce et que
toutes ces femmes et moi on était
impuissante à faire quoi que ce soit et
et tout le long du retour dans la
voiture je j'ai pensé mon dieu c'est
quelque chose
à l'époque tout allait bien entre mon
mari et moi et moi j'avais quand même
beaucoup de facilité c'est à dire que
mon mari les enfants étaient plus petits
accepté ma manière d'éduquer les enfants
et j'ai eu une angoisse profonde en me
disant mais si quelque chose arrivait à
gaza et inde
un de ses frères devenez un sur le
tuteur les enfants et là c'était
vraiment peur c'est la première fois
qu'on me dit en anglais le premier corps
oui vous avez raison la larme
l'alarmé qui ne m'a plus jamais quitté
et je crois que ça à partir de ce moment
là où j'ai commencé à observer pour les
petits détails de l'arabie saudite les
tout ce qui pourrait tout ce qui se
passait pour essayer d'analyser de
comprendre et eux et c'est une autre
fois aussi où vous croisez oussama ben
laden
vous êtes chez vous dans le jardin on
sonne à la porte vous l'ouvrez sans
réfléchir il vous voit
et qu'est-ce qui se passe il se retourne
dans la vingtaine et il me regarde et je
me regarde et se tourner c'était
quelques secondes vous fait signe de
partir et il me fait comme ça et je n'ai
pas réalisé ce jeu les civils je dis no
és lamela et son neveu qui était avec
lui m'a dit ça ou ça m'a aidé et j'ai
réalisé ces nous sommes alors je suis
parti c'est à dire qu'oussama il a
toujours été comme ça quoi depuis son
plus jeune âge il était extrêmement qui
eux est alors proposée pour ses frères
pour sa famille il est une sorte de
héros j'imagine parce que il est parti
se battre en afghanistan et tout ça en
plus d'avoir de l'argent il a une espèce
de sacralité un petit peu comme ramed
chèque le le père non avant de partir en
afghanistan sa main était un frère comme
les autres et après quand il est parti
en afghanistan pour se battre contre les
soviétiques et il est devenu un héros
pour pas seulement la famille ben laden
pour du monde pour tout le monde tout le
monde pourquoi vous avez écrit ce
bouquin côté ce bouquin c'est une
explique l'explication d'une mère et ses
filles parce que je sais que mes filles
ont eu un prix émotionnel à payer pour
parce qu'elle s'appelle ben laden et
pour les décisions que j'ai prises pour
elle c'est à dire que je sais que si
j'avais accepté de suivre les règles
saoudienne et de les élever un peu plus
dans l'est dans la culture saoudienne
peut-être qu'elle n'aurait pas été
rejetés par leur famille et je crois que
ça a été très douloureux pour mes filles
d'être
rejeté par la famille elles ont lu le
bouquin au fait oui disent quoi elles
m'ont dit qu'elle aimait mon enfant
c'est bien nous venons le média c'est
fantastique et c'est très bien quand
vous dites j'ai vécu au sein du clan ben
laden
je connais la société saoudienne et j'ai
peur pour l'avenir de l'humanité
c'est-à-dire que vous pensez que
finalement la culture occidentale ne
peut rien faire finalement face à ces
fondamentalistes prêt à tout vous savez
j'appelle les fondamentalistes une armée
de l'ombre
ils sont là on ne sait pas si vous
regardez les tragédie du 11-septembre
3900 détruit comme ça avec et avec
quelles armes un avion donc vous prenez
que je prends tout le monde prend et 19
personnes
après une année après avoir passé une
année dans une société qui n'a pas pu
les influencer en quoi trésor ont mis en
exécution
ils ont besoin de prendre notre
technologie pour le retourner contre
nous et ça c'est sa maîtresse vous
croyez en l'islam modéré
j'aimerais croire en islam modéré ou ce
qui me fait peur aussi si vous savez
quand je suis allé en au début des
années soixante quatorze en arabie
saoudite l'arabie saoudite est le seul
pays qui étaient sous la halle sur la
charia et ce quand je regarde tout ce
qui s'est passé
malgré tout toute cette évolution ya eu
dans le monde de plus en plus de pays
demandent et ça ça mettrait iran quand
vous voyez à leur jeu
oui je crois qu'il ya parce qu'autrement
ce serait terrible s'il n'y avait pas un
islam modéré soeur pensez quoi de la
querelle
du voile à l'école en france écoutez je
je je trouve que je ne peux pas accepter
quand conforme
koné a accepté le voile ici parce que
vous savez ça sécurise et en arabie
saoudite par exemple ils ont une moitié
de la population qui est qui et
étrangères ils ont beaucoup de
philippins deux qui sont de religion
catholique
il n'y a pas une seule église pour
d'accord et quand je vois ces excuses
moi ces femmes qui descendent dans la
rue et qui revendique 2 le port du voile
dans une société laïque et qui veulent
que nous on oublie notre culture à nous
et au sens où vous êtes et ces femmes
quand il ya encore pas si longtemps il
ya trois ans le régime taliban étaient
en train de primer leur servent
pourquoi elles sont pas descendus et
avant les mêmes revendications pour un
pour un régime qui opprime et normal oui
vous vous pensez quoi vous pensez que
les clés français disons les européens
les occidentaux peu importe vous pensez
qu'ils sont trop finalement faible face
à ça vous pensez que ici le côté
république chacun fait ce qu'il veut ça
donne trop de possibilités je pense que
je pense que on doit être vigilant qu'il
n'utilise pas notre indulgence pour pour
imposer leurs rangs tolérance voilà
carmen ben laden donc le voile déchirée
c'est chez michel lafon merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous avons choisi
quand même
béchir est
debbie précieux du ciel la face
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant la honda 6
je vous demande de vous arrêter au lot
no comment ça va ça va j'ai bien fait de
pouvoir le blouson il faut encore plus
fort l'accusé car malgré la non là c'est
fort ce 9 s'est pas coupé
est-ce qu'on peut dédier cette émission
à ticky holgado volontiers voilà
[Applaudissements]
volontiers
et moi je voudrais dire bonsoir à kamel
voilà et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
on n'a pas
[Musique]
toi
ça fait
common et claironne le brouillard
voici les connards
[Musique]
et
les connards mesdames messieurs bons
mots j'interprétais temps
bonsoir les nrj music awards
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
pourquoi
oui pourquoi je suis né
après tout cela
récré où il ajouté
je pense d'elle
tenez
depuis cette époque avec les potes dans
les soirées ont fini sans substance
je suis tout
cet été
gamigo liga
m
on colle mais pour geeker aux
tourniquets way qu'elle les canards se
soit on s'en fout on rfo en nous
ça va
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oui
moi
et
[Musique]
sur les bassins
c'est fait
[Musique]
oh
il a les moyens
[Musique]
oh
yann et enfants
madame braga
voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'était comme des canards
interprété par les connards
blais
asseyez-vous
[Applaudissements]
je me demande de vous arrêter vous
demande de vous arrêter
je vais vous dire franchement on peut
pas en faire 40 comme ça c'est fort
bravo donc c'est la bande opérait à
l'égard de mon client fleuves chao de
bruay
donc c'est la bande originale du film
les 11 commandements donc comme des
connards par la callas on me dit qu'il
faut la refaire pas à ses péchés
j'ai écrit ça les paroles ouais
les paroles c'est nous la musique c'est
les nac ce qui avait notamment fait môme
my sharona
[Musique]
nicolas
si on jamais
ap
oh
le plagiat dans l'autre sens ouais c'est
que les knacks nous nous on nous ont
plagié mes 12 ans avant démarre alors
c'est un groupe met au point qu'on peut
dire les connards néo néo néo néo
beaucoup d aude hérault pas goûté aux
quelles sont vos influences musicales
zii egg zh ouais ouais gentillette way
white stripes voix et puis les vertes et
iron maiden dont j'attends votre et
comment on est innocent dans un club
échangiste grossit à chaque fois
responsable des confins de musique c'est
toujours entre 500 et surgissent et
jalalabad est ensemble depuis longtemps
les connards oui trop alors est-ce que
vous avez des envies de carrière solo
les canards ne débarque le problème
c'est que dans déjà dans le groupe il y
en a que deux qui chantent
ouais et les deux qui chante s'il
n'avait pas eu recours à comme on
appelle ça c'est toi qui as you are est
l'auto tune
je n'avais pas eu égard les personnes
qui changent la nation merci voilà on
voudrais surtout remercier l'auto-tune
sans lui en existera
qu'est ce qu'il ya
des chanteurs qui vont nrj music awards
j'avais pas déconner on va pas aux nrj
music awards un chardy sont 500 pas les
couilles ouais en fait aux champions des
bras on me le dit assez souvent que si
je ressemblais un petit feu alphonse
brown s'est envolé de bratislava qui sur
ses bases qui sont données
[Musique]
content qu'il soit mort cela bon c'est
pas ce qu'ils sont devenus
mais remarquez quand même que ils ont
progressé depuis
musicalement ils se seraient ils ont
découvert qu'ils buvaient quand même
faire un morceau quitté la route c'est
pas de leur sort et ça c'est pas de leur
[ __ ] c'est grâce à leurs deux jours
ouais ça va cartonner
l'école
mollo
m
je le fais
soit
alors maintenant on va voir si vous êtes
de vrais connards on va faire le
questionnaire de proust
[Musique]
là
quel est pour vous le comble de la
misère des goûteurs chez buffalo de riz
mais croit la star academy corps qui
avez votre idéal de bonheur terrestre
c'est chez d'être d'être chez toi dans
ton canapé
ouais de foot des grandes gagnantes on
vient d'insulter ta femme de pas
t'occuper de ton gosse et de regarder
bataille et fontaine en se grattant les
coins pizza pizza pizza pour quelle
faute avez-vous le plus d'indulgence à
faute de goût quelle est la qualité que
vous préférez chez l'homme sa femme
[Applaudissements]
la qualité vous préférez c'est la femme
sa fille qui auriez-vous aimé être si
vous étiez pas les connards potes
oui car il a évité que vous appréciez le
plus chez vos amis quand ils s'en vont
j'avais votre principal défaut amazon
air mais ça va être compliqué à
expliquer je soutiens le front national
mais c'est pour des raisons éminemment
politique c'est j'ai décidé que si nous
on soutenait le front national tous les
électeurs du front national mais vous ne
voulez pas se reconnaître dans ce vote
vont le laisser tomber à l'eau
[Musique]
salafistes monsieur
la première c'est ce qui les attire
c'est une femme à la tête de son c'est
la taille de son entraîneur ce que vous
détestez par dessus tout et ça tu as
toujours des trucs à répondre tout le
temps oui mais j'ai ma carte des
banquiers mois dont j'ai bossé
non mes gardes il faut de la reprendre
ouais il à la semaine dernière à deux
visions cours il a repris dans la
chambre et regardez regardez les
chaussures qu'elle lui a offert la salle
bon une pause insultes ah ouais
jean tigana pour une pause bisou à la
wii
non
[Musique]
comment aimeriez-vous mourir à neuilly
sur seine
oui moi je veux mourir à lui je sais
devant l'aca
attention
allez qu'elle est à présent de votre
esprit est à présent quel est votre
devise européenne
comme tout le monde en fait notre vraie
nature c'est d'avoir 14 ans quand une
voiture sans toucher au volant saleh
pendant mon sport
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
ouais jusqu'à nous
on s'en fout on l'élève où on le faire
mais carrasso
[Musique]
ap ap
non
vous voyez pas dans le wiki je donnais
floride
vinci alain chabat et jean paul rouve
à la java ee jean-paul rault mesdames
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
laurent merci d'en
les gentils
merci beaucoup c'est vous
et et l'eau et leurs mamans
ouais
bonsoir s'il est beau mais là bien sûr
vous à quelques membres françoise
bonsoir c'est aussi jeudi jabbar deux
noms de faire des petits quand même ses
formes il a déclaré à l'ats elle a eu
six merveilleusement vous espériez pas
tant qu'entité vous je pensais pas qu'il
était comme un petit effectif allégé par
ailleurs de gros un peu plus gros gégé
il
il avait pas moustaches et l'âme et à la
semaine il avait déjà des tendances avec
bâle mêmes que maintenant peut-être qui
est aussi maman rappelles tu t'es sorti
de l'alcool en fait pas maintenant parce
que qu'est-ce qui on attend les gens pas
très choquée quand vous allez chercher à
l'école quand on était petits c'était
bourré devant l'écossé vomi souffert de
ça alors il ne faut plus en parler parce
que sa valeur ouais alv.xe his way c'est
sûr ils se tirent toujours sur
l'élastique série va pas passer bah oui
à quel âge il a commencé à l'un
une mi temps et demie oui un peu un peu
retardé tu sais plus tôt mais sérieux
qu'il avait le bouton rouge toujours oui
c'est yeux il était en veille déjà comme
un chien tu sais on dit on fera bondir
la suite amené à la barre son père
on rappelle que bruce lee mais également
la maman de eric et ramzy on embrasse au
passage mais vous dis au revoir on va
les filles à toute heure
dans la loge après l'émission bref un an
ck oui c'est beau c'est un grand moment
de télévision
c'est bon il y a
les goals et ma mère ouais je ne savais
pas qu'elle était goy du nord n'aurait
pas bien alors vous êtes ici pour la
sortie d'un des films les plus attendus
de l'année qui s'appelle voilà donc
c'est un film écrit par ils ont fait
exprès en fait pour ça c'est fait pour
ça donc à la caisse vous ayez acheté les
billets ce sera pour jouer une place
prend donc un film qui est écrit par les
robins en collaboration avec alain
chabat joué par les robins et alain
chabat plus depardieu rochefort valérie
lemercier dominique farrugia font des
apparitions pour le maître est sollicité
par action voilà et réalisé par alain
chabat alors le pitch je vais le faire
hein je crois que ce sera beaucoup plus
simple
le pitch mais d'abord le fond c'est le
premier thriller préhistorique
nous sommes en pleine préhistoire moins
trente cinq mille ans avant jésus-christ
et pour la première fois un crime est
commis
c'est la première fois qu'un homme tue
un autre homme alors pourquoi tu es qui
a tué c'est pour ça que j'ai dit le
premier thriller préhistoriques sur la
première fois que que la sphère se pose
est au niveau de la forme c'est beaucoup
moins métaphysique mais c'est le premier
dessin animé dont les personnages sont
des vrais acteurs je crois qu'on peut le
dire
1 j'aime bien ouais c'est gentil ouais
si c'est marina qu'à 10 heures alors
voilà donc elles attribuent des cheveux
sales qui veut voler le secret du
shampoing à la tribu des cheveux propres
et ce qu'elle le vaut bien
voilà
et alors tout le monde s'appelle pierre
parce qu'on est à l'âge de pierre
et puis les animaux évidemment il ya des
des poules goutte chez les canards
mousse et puis il ya des vermouth qu'on
a ici derrière voilà ça c'est une espèce
de petite poule rousse brune poules
moutons
voilà ça c'est quoi ça ailleurs tout ça
c'est un oeil en cochons moutons ça
c'est le lapin moody énergie ma le lapin
mouthe et puis il ya le foot
lorsque voilà donc ça se passe quand on
goûte ya des mammouths mais pas de mode
voilà c'est porte nawak en fait c'est
tout n'ont cessé basé sur des faits
réels et il ya eu beaucoup de recherches
sur le sur le sujet notamment chasse et
on est maintenant retrouver sa grande
époque
vous avez retrouvé des documents dits
blancs bien sûr un puisque la couleur
n'existe qu'à l'époque vous voyez donc
forcément les enregistrements d'assez
mauvaise qualité mais qui nous entraîne
permis de travail et une base une base
coiffe un devoir à la véracité
voilà des bien sûr et beaucoup de drogue
[Musique]
il y a trente cinq mille ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
senda hotahota aux dogues à rien ce que
vous dites mais innover
et où les enfants n'avaient rien de
mieux à faire que de regarder la fresque
allez on éteint la seule comédie
préhistorique de 2004 est aussi la
première enquête de tous les temps sans
face à quelque chose qui n'est jamais
arrivé j'appelle ce quelque chose
il était comment l'idée de vaud fait une
descente au village on aurait tous les
types qui était de 2 hier l'inquiétude
qu'elle d'amour dé tout ça sera terminé
je m'occuperai de toi les robins des
bois gérard depardieu tout et je crois
qu'il faut raison garder la foi tu vas
te le permet
alain chabat penser à un truc là non
vous ne marchez sur les cheveux pardon
en janvier
[Musique]
préparez-vous à retenir
à l'âge de pierre sa lumière le
nucléaire mais vous pouvez prononcé rrr
aussi si vous voulez
ça va ça va
un jardin avec ses rangs le genre jeu
j'aurais payant
ex berger dire tout le monde
jean paul bret le personnage du vous
appelez le blond non mais vous m'appelez
pierre j'aime pas qu'on appelle le blond
vous sentez un petit peu différent des
autres
là oui c'est d'ailleurs c'est un film
sur la différence je crois tu peux le
dire tout de suite voilà je suis seule
blonde la tribu et je vis je vis assez
mal la différence pour ça que je suis un
personnage un peu renfermé
c'est un peu un personnage et la clau de
sauter dans le film j'ai aperçu quelque
chose quelque chose de sauter mais sans
romy schneider et michel piccoli mais
bon un drame rural
c'est un personnage assez épais au
milieu de tout ça un personnage un peu
tourmenté voilà un peu tourmenté c'est
la première fois que je fais ce genre de
personnage
ouais je suis très content mais c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un remarque
ouais mais oui c'est vrai on parlera
jamais bah voilà si si je l'étais
remarier fort j'ai vu et j'ai eu du mal
à faire seuls alors que ça ça s'appelle
donc c'est chabal et robin j'ai déjà dit
trois fois sortie nationale le 28
janvier 700 copies mais sûrement un
cinéma près de chez vous qu'il le joue
parce que 700 copies c'est énorme non
oui oui alors que le sar pas de vanne
[ __ ] pas de vannes
ouais mais sans copier par rapport à
cet office et c'est beaucoup vous
comptez faire quand même entré à la à
peu près avec mon film précédent a fait
14 millions et demi d'entrées devant se
faire doubler
ouais donc je pense qu'on va faire à la
la je prends ma sphère est ce qu'on va
faire ce sera plus sûr on va faire
plusieurs prises en juillet vous comptez
faire quand même en prie vous allez me
répondre d'abord 14,6 millions quand à
dire quand même très bas 14,6 millions
là maintenant vous me dire si millions
vous êtes à combien d'entrés vous voulez
le vrai chiffre non je veux le
schifflangeois puis je prendrai la
meilleure prise en fonction des entrées
comme un nom ouais d'accord ça comme ça
vous aurez raison vous aurez toujours
présent en dit moins 6 millions alors je
vais faire comme entre 6 millions 6
millions mais on en fait encore eu aussi
le maire croit migraine pour moi oui
comme elle entraîne et que dire de 2
milliards alors nous n'aurons ça fait
quand même très vite on filme 2
milliards
il ya des milliards ce sont les pertes
de la production en anciens francs en
anciens francs
[Applaudissements]
quand tu vas me faire 190 d'entre eux
c'est faire comme l entrée 180000 comme
d'affilée
alors est ce que vous êtes attaché de
presse sont là comme je crois que vous
viviez myriam et myriam henggi rien mais
la très bien que myriam on va leur faire
plaisir on va faire les questions du
dossier de presse comme ça il n'y aura
pas de dire a pas de problème mais on
est sûr que vous vous rendrez le fit
alors comment êtes vous arrivé sur ce
projet alain chabat c'est amusant que
vous me posiez cette question
comme comme producteur d'abord dominique
farrugia qui devait initialement
produire le film a été appelé pour
diriger canal+
bon ce poste allée lui prendre 120 % de
son temps il m'a donc contact avec les
robins des bois pour savoir si je
voulais produire c'est bien non mais ça
fait vraiment de cinéma je me connais
vraiment rien peut-être les gens sont
pas habitués à la spontanéité 3 même
temps allez-vous avoir du plaisir à
jouer même avec la pression de votre
double fonction alain chabat vous
réalisez que vous jouez sur février
mission de cinéma là c'est une bonne
question que personne n'a jamais posé ça
me fait plaisir
ardisson bon j'adore jouer j'adore
réaliser mais c'est vrai que les deux en
même temps n'était pas mon exercice
favori tout dire les jours où je faisais
acteur réalisateur
gt gt d'une humeur de d'ogm août
c'est très désagréable pour l'équipe
entre parenthèses qu'elle soit remerciée
pour sa patience mais ça m'a bien aidé
pour le rôle très bien
n'aurait-il pas été plus simple de
trouver le film en studio alors on ya
pensé et puis finalement jean rochefort
accepté ouais
souvenirs garderez-vous de leur voisine
c'est toi j'ai entendu à laon début de
la question alain chabat à quels
souvenirs garderez-vous de haut il y en
a beaucoup tout ce joyeux liés au
bonheur de travailler avec des gens
décidés à donner le meilleur
quant aux robins il travaille autant
qu'ils déconnent qu'ils se sont de très
gros bosseur
merci alors jean paul et vous tu
préoccupés par leur épargne et vous et
vous et vous et vous attend les
figurants juste après l'été durant le
témoignage de figurants une forme de
quoi
jean paul raconte c'est pas ça jean paul
à la plage non plus jean-paul à l
érection ces paroles font l'espagne 6 la
terrestre nom jean pierre leblon
d'attributs machine et vous direz vous
on s'est excusé moi aussi excusez moi
l'école jean paul pourquoi dans tout
processus berger lol
nous attendons toujours
demandez moi l'adhésion de tous leurs
oeufs extrait de la bo du film alors sur
la bo yahia joey starr ya ophélie winter
il ya fabuleux aussi à busta flex il ya
superbus
ouais on l'aimé bien c'est les fans de
jenifer et bien non il ya le making of
en papier alors ça c'est extraordinaire
donc il ya le scénario semble pour ben
voilà ça c'est vraiment ton fils adorent
l'ordre si la bible et jouit grave
il a aussi découvert les répliques il ya
le scénario original il y avait
storyboard je vous dessinez très bien
monsieur chabat merci tient vraiment et
puis à des photos aussi du tournage
enfin ses textures bien maman nul et
puis aller et puis elle et peluches
aussi évidemment les biens des photos
des peluches voix et maintenant
interview sans la bouche
[Musique]
jean-paul interviews sont la bouche
attention ne dit rien vous êtes dans une
soirée claude berri vous vous salue en
vous appelant jean pierre rives
vous êtes obligé de sourire parce que
c'est claude berri vous souriez comment
alain dans la même soirée nicolas
sarkozy arrive vous salue vous parle
vous félicite
un photographe arrive fait quelle tête
sur la photo jean-paul à ce moment là
une sublime gonzesses entre ne regarde
que vous vous êtes inaccessible fait
kate est inaccessible mais pas trop
inaccessible mais pas trop ouais mais
pas trop inaccessible inaccessible je
suis excessivement au patro pas trop
voilà nicole kidman arrive dans cette
soirée où il ya claude berri déjà
nicolas sarkozy est nécessaire tazi et
alors vous voient comme c'est fait aïe
alan vous faites quoi vous le font parce
que c'est kidman excuses il dit qu'est
ce qui fait que ce blaireau jean-paul
vous vous croisez quelqu'un de
visiblement important en fait vous
l'avez pas reconnu c'est le nouveau
comics et alain delon fait quelle tête
génériques et jean paul jean pierre
guérin le producteur de gilles escot
vous raconte vos débuts dans la série il
vous propose de revenir dans la série
julie lescaut à un million de francs
l'épisode pizza pizza pizza millions de
francs épisode alors vous embarquez
nicole kidman on est lui lui moi je
rencontre jean pierre guérin julie les
friteuses shimano marque nicole kidman
c'est le real en même temps vous prenez
votre voiture vous allez prendre un
dernier verre au costes et là vous lui
dites nicole contrairement à ce que tout
le monde croit je ne suis pas d'oran je
suis américain kader aoun je t'emmerde
ça c'est pour commencer
oui moi quand je fais l'américain je
suis un peu classe fait comme ça à
quelques mois
jean vol
vous quittez le soir et à votre tour
j'en avais marre d'être avec ses
retombées sur marion gamme guerre vous
allez vous allez au cost ouais t'es vous
rencontrer alain chabat et nicole kidman
qui s'en plaint de prendre un dernier
verre il fait l'américain vous vous
asseyez vous êtes là tous les trois ou
quatre coups et bien c'est le coup
ophélie winter arrive chez bonjour au
fil des mois comme chose dans les
cheveux je peux pas parler et là elle me
demande pourquoi
bah c'est un truc ardisson à dire
bonjour normalement
et en bas
le bar du genre
lemercier de l'unique route
avec jeu
josé
michaël youn michael 12 ans de pouce
c'est qui la blonde avec vous ah ouais
rappelons que s'est offert dans la
production
comment ça s'est passé avec elles n'ont
pas les trois lots
[Musique]
oui
k
[Musique]
et j'aimais
où
et
ouais
acharnement dans la lutte
non
m
là
c'est cela
chabarot
sa mère
quand vous arrêtez cap vert qu'est ce
qui se passe au niveau de la dépendance
à la roquette à bouger d'atours tout à
l'heure
le 28 janvier le sort et une semaine
après heureusement vous ne serez pas en
face le mercredi la place pour tout le
monde quand les films sont bien les gens
vont au cinéma
oui enfin quant à nemo le seigneur des
anneaux tiens c'était des moules
seigneur des anneaux j'étais parti pour
les [ __ ] tous les deux c'est un
contre-temps voilà on le 4 février soit
huit jours après le sortir à votre
nouveau film qui s'appelle les 11
commandements produit par un bennahmias
qu'on conseille aux passagers mon entrée
salade bien sûr vraiment est adorable
très complaisante et réalisé par lé real
de madrid oui fameuse équipe d'airé à la
bassée rire car en fait les deux
réalisateurs avaient tellement ils ont
préféré similé real de madrid
alors non moi je veux faire le pitch
alors je vous laisse le dossier je vais
car le pitch alors le monde va mal les
humains ne rigole plus c'est grave
le dieu de la blague dieudonné ça
j'avoue que le tube like the dawn est
bon aux portes des données oui n'a plus
qu'une solution donc c'est michaël youn
et sa bande 1 cc alors c'est tout
l'argument décisif parce que tous les
autres comics est occupé à faire
d'autres films koala ou encore podium
voilà jeu sortira sept jours après mais
je tiens à dire allez voir podium parce
que c'est un très bon film et ses sept
jours après voilà alors la mission de
michaël youn et sa bande c'est accomplir
les 11 commandements de la blague
et là c'est nouveau c'est que c'est en
vrai sait on ce défi qu'on a fait en
vrai dans la rue tourné caméra au poing
avec des jarres et c'est nouveau c'est
en vrai un origine dans un égout
c'est un peu dans l'esprit de du morning
live de jackass c'est à dire une tonne
green voilà vous avez tourné tous ces
défis pour de vrai alors êtes-vous dit
michael dans ce dossier de presse
puisque là ce soir au reste pour faire
plaisir là c'est pour faire plaisir à
enzo enzo qu'on embrasse son attaché de
presse
vous qui habitez toulouse vous ne
comprenez rien cette émission ça n'est
pas grave
changez ville michael louie vous dites
dans le dossier de presse on me
proposait des comédies traditionnel mais
j'ai le temps pour le traditionnel je
voulais expérimenter autre chose je ne
sais pas qui a écrit le dossier de
presse aussi bien non c'est un on
voulait essayer de voir si c'était
possible de cinéma d'apporter une
proposition un peu alternative aux
divertissements qui a d'habitude voire
c'était possible de rigoler autrement au
cinéma voilà c'est ce qu'on essaye en
queue de poisson mais en somme a très
bien briefé monsieur ya eu alternative
du divertissement
le film très originaux ce soir
effectivement vous voyez bien chers amis
téléspectateurs il ya d'abord un
thriller préhistorique et ensuite du
cinéma en live donc c'était vraiment de
films très très originaux très
particulier et ça nous montre la vigueur
du cinéma français
donc j'espère c'est le dieu de la blague
donc il ya un an on fait tirer des coups
francs dans le bide à venir ici serial
c'est la deuxième plus grosse frappe
d'europe après roberto carlos ça va à
210 kilomètres ça ça fait mal mais comme
ça fait rigoler les gens c'est pas un
avancement et amélie mauresmo a aussi
qui vous suit des balles de service en
place et 180 kilomètres heure mais c'est
pas du sang et puis aller mais où est le
problème
au même endroit selon elle arrive à être
visé le bas l'union se faisait piquer
par des guêpes l arrivée de la lecture
de la guerre
quels seront alors le plus dur c'était
quoi la pesanteur la pesanteur on est
allé le plus dur pour la pesanteur c'est
déjà d'aller en russie mais je veux oui
c'est un cauchemar sera tout à l'heure
avec elena mais c'est un cauchemar ce
pays on bouffe mal on vous parle mal
elle traite mal toute la journée
non papa les noix du prix rentrer dans
la chambre pendant qu'on dormait pour
nous dire je vais toujours été prête
était toujours amélie mauresmo
le plus difficile a été la centrifugeuse
vois le truc c'est comme ça que tu as un
brad 18 mètres il peut aller jusqu'à 30
g tu pèses 30 fois ton corps mais là il
ya que les cafards qui résiste nous on
est allé jusqu'à 6 g les cosmonautes
vont jusqu'à 8
oui mais le problème c'est que tout le
sang se concentre dans la tête donc tu
veux bien plus rien bah ouais tu vomis
ouais t'as pas le choix
tout le monde est beau mais il y en a
qui vomissent avec le sourire moi
j'aimerais vous versez en vallouise
alors vous êtes dans un avion donc un
iliouchine aurait fait à 15 mètres
d'altitude d'un vol parabolique et vous
êtes en apesanteur sont nés les premiers
français à l'avoir fait au cinéma
le truc c'est que c'est qu'on était une
trentaine dans l'île ue chine
il y avait vingt français des russes les
vins français étaient tous malades on
veut on vomit c'est carrément dans des
sacs poubelle il j'avais des données des
sacs poubelle pour vomir dans les russes
il souhaite être notre but des cocktails
je vous avez une formation avant une
formation est clairement sept minutes
nous ont dit que peut-être à la fin de
la parabole les gaz de l'élu qui
n'arriveraient pas à redémarrer beaucoup
à ce moment là faudrait sauter en
parachute et sans traductrice quatre
minutes ils nous ont appris à sauter en
parachute peut dire que quand le vol
comme ancêtre et ça c'est utile parce
que tu dis comment on dit m
y'a un moment aussi énorme vous êtes
stade gerland à lyon donc en face de la
tribune des bad gones sélectionnés parmi
les plus méchants de france avec le kop
de boulogne et certains du travail on
vous présente comme un groupe de
saint-etienne auxerre saint-etienne et
lyon c'est à côté l'om et paris 6 mois
la petite charrette et vous chantez le
lion est mort ce soir à lyon à huit cent
quarante mille personnes nous ont jeté
des téléphones portables véridique et la
blague qu'on faisait ses on va revenir
l'année prochaine vous nous montrez les
chargeurs arrête faut pas creuser région
at on créé une faille spatio temporelle
est aspiré toutes les molécules de ton
corps danger une dimension parallèle
[ __ ] voici les 11 commandements de la
blague que vous aurez à accomplir pour
remettre les peuples dans le droit
chemin
larry graham
et n'oubliez pas maintenant en mission
pour que
rien de quoi vous avez touche
non
quel nom
face aux chiffres othman bonjour je
crois que ma mère aussi ce produit
seulement quatre potes avec tout ça
bouge à 80 postes à des pistes avait dit
messieurs votre attention s'il vous
plaît j'ai dans la main une boîte de ce
médicament qu'on appelle médicaments
d'amour qui permet à tous les vieux de
se transformer en véritable aimant
e
encore toi maintenant
[Musique]
tout être humain servir c'est pourquoi
je suis
dans le tas
recchi oui on loue ses jeux
crotte de nez
je suis allé
dans les
tout seul
si le moment
qui sont là les autres
cette saloperie un beau c'est beau
personnage j'avais fait des lectures on
a travaillé à pizza comme ça qu'on a
bossé non on en a fait des saloperies et
celle là c'est de loin celle dont on est
le plus fier d'y avoir redonné c'est à
bouira les crottes de nez il faut que là
ils sont ici suis sur des flics et c'est
celui qui a le plus morfler oui c'est
lui qui a fait ça elle est vraiment
resté si longtemps garde à vue qu'on l'a
mis doseur garder parce que c'est des
matières fécales sur un flic c'est
vraiment un autre c'est considéré comme
matière michael vous tortiller beaucoup
du cul dans ce film un petit riche tu
m'as dit que sa tête avait plus tard oui
mais justement c'est pour ça que j'ai
remarqué que j'embarque wayside stock
traquenard on retourne chez courbet
[Musique]
alors un hommage à votre qu on va faire
une interview au slip sur la tête morale
elle
celui de la fin
un dos en ce moment il est
particulièrement stressés slip mais
qu'elle était du côté france d'en bas
attendons toujours
est-ce que c'est agréable à porter
pardon maman pourquoi est ce que allah
jean-paul ils en ont pas parce que
j'avais des césar
est ce que vous pensez michael que le
monde irait mieux si tout le monde avait
un slip sur la tête je pense que le
monde irait mieux si les gens veulent le
porter à l'envers comme une casquette de
john d'accord super ça bien compliquée
avec émotion maintenant elle le sera pas
dans un autre pour éviter de me poser
des questions je suis capable de donner
du sens à mes réponses parce qu'en ce
moment j'ai l'impression d'avoir une
femme sortes de fonctions sociales et il
est un peu je me la contra boucherit
votre film est très très libertaires
très imprégnée de l'esprit on
al'impression un petit peu on se demande
quand même que c'est l'apocalypse a
atterri à que des émissions de
classement comme s'il fallait tout bien
rangée avant que ce soir armageddon donc
voila c'était un petit peu histoire de
dire merde commander sur service public
aura à faire des questions qui peut plus
intelligente et pensez vous comme
nietzsche que ce qui ne vous tue pas
vous rend plus fort ça c'est kyo qu'il a
dit d'europe qui pensez vous comme un
vrai mâle roux que le but d'une vie
c'est de transformer son expérience en
conscience oui
c'est le cd
mais bon on a pris une interview avec
vincent et la france
le journaliste lui a demandé s'il y
avait un sens et vincent répondu on
aimerait l'autre mais non justement
bon à la dernière question la merde quoi
t'as pas ce sixième sens avec les
fringues c'est à cause de son absence
est vide
vincent oui bon c'est vous comme
benjamin castaldi à paris enfin tous ces
méchants quoi est il faut taper 1
si tu veux thiery sorte que ce soit fini
par nous ses résultats et fait toujours
ici pourquoi je sais plus pourquoi je
suis venu
m
regardez un peu plus et marratier je
suis un peu embêté oui j'ai trouvé qu'on
ait baha surtout benjamin ah ouais ouais
je ne sais pas trouvé assez présent
j'étais mauvais oui ça m'a je te propose
de conflits jeunes commission n'importe
laquelle
quelle punition tu veux lui faire
michael je voudrais qu'ils nous chantent
du film barbe et un aboyeur de papier
ouais ça les notions de papier aller
benjamin com
pas dupes ils arrivent quand je la
regarde moi l'homme est lourd lacker
dassier devant un corps de femme ouais
je suis un g12 papier
les bébés je l'accueille plus que j'ai
pour l'été
c'est ma tendresse
je suis un géant aux pieds
ouais et
je fais un mode nuit d'angoissé en
maintenant des mails pour vous michael
un mail de l'ukba retour et d'orléans
nom de l'ue par tours et d'orléans sa
paille comme est ce que vous pensez
michael quinze jours à venir vous voir
en vous disant que c'est terminé tout ça
qu'il faut font de l'argent qu'il faut
pas rester là c'était des gens qui
travaillent et j'espère si ça n'arrivait
pas un jour ça va être ça voudrait dire
que tout ça ne cessez de ses noces en
soit voilà n'a aucun sens exactement ce
que je voulais dire j'avais envie de
citer vincent merci
l éviter
passons
benjamin yens 2 pas nourri et oui
ça commence à bat yam n étiez pas fier
je n'ai aucune mais c'est rigolo du ces
[ __ ] et maintenant
mais j'aime y jouer ce soir bressy et na
li na
[Musique]
bonsoir elle est fâchée parce que vous
êtes fâché non bonsoir je m'excuse
d'avancé pour toutes mes fautes en
français jusqu'à des caisses que il a
envie de voyager cela vous êtes
clitoridienne non non non non on a dit
pas au début ce genre de scène originale
du coup on est tous les deux d'accord on
est tous contents ils sont tous les deux
premiers tours non non non non c'était
tous les deux non non quand je dis on
est tous les deux attendez mais continue
lna non bien on se bat non non non non
mais attendez vous allez pas me laisser
cette semaine une fille à pipe
oyo
piret
c'est comme ça ces modèles
[Musique]
voilà l'homme rouge tout le monde se
donne aux halles et je crains la
nouvelle adresse à l épreuve il adresse
un bon soir devant se retirer
pourquoi pourquoi elle et na li nina est
pas elena staline a pour l'instant ça se
passe bien parce que les mines en russe
ça signifie c'est lui qui appartient à
elena et moi je suis tellement en
dépendantes dans ma vie malheureusement
que je pense que j'appartiens que à moi
alors j'ai lu dans france soir
france soir du 6 mai 2010 à 6 excusez
nous ils voient pas derrière accepté de
s'asseoir tout le monde ça
alors et nager j'ai lu dans france soir
du 6 mai 2003 une déclaration importante
de vous vous dites
le baiser russe c'est sans la langue en
baisse un peu la lumière on baisse un
petit peu la lumière voilà on me laisse
avec les veinards alors c'est vrai que
le baiser russe et sur la langue
c'est vrai que les français ont
énormément des stéréotypes des fantasmes
des russes des clichés ça fait partie de
ces stéréotypes qui sont pas vrai que
les russes s'embrasse sur la bouche
chaque fois que se voit en effet des
virus s'embrasse pas plus souvent sur la
bouche que les français il rapporte
qu'elle est maman
j'aimais
[Musique]
ouais
donc j'ai eu mon baiser russe
effectivement je me dirais c'est sans la
langue c'est sans la langue certes eu
d'yeux que tu pousses célèbre quand
l'élève de la fille mais non non ça ce
qu'elle a sur les lèvres
brad moi tu me filme pas alors moi je
suis d'affiner la rend plus bas j'aime
pas ta gueule ouverte
alors bon et là on est tous les deux on
se pose beaucoup de questions c'est
chrome os je pose beaucoup de questions
à votre sujet quel est votre véritable
âge bon tu me fais peur parce que parce
que non je vous dire pour voir ce qu'il
en ait les épaules on accepter les gens
19 à 29 ans et on a dit l'ong là que ce
soit on est là pour tordre le cou à
toutes les rumeurs
on a dit que vous aviez plus que 29 ans
on avait dit pâtit c'est toi qui
craquent qui courait sur ton film ou pas
loin
or actuellement dans la foule
vous étiez en vacances et donc vous avez
moins de 29 ans il est là sinon vous
n'auriez pas été acceptée un high speed
ball
on est d'accord nature et alain laurent
on va te reprendre toutes les cartes et
là alors on a dit que des teens vedette
de télévision en russie vrai faux
oui non info ou intox j'ai une émission
hebdomadaire pour le vent majorettes et
cette émission mais je vais repasser
avec un autre projet à chaque semaine
alors c'est une émission hebdomadaire
pardon la traduction je ne me retrouve
plus c'est qui la traduction la et
dimitri bien à l'ena et là encore si
nulle part continue on retire concentrez
vous regardez moi on a dit que dans
l'aspi paul devient une espèce de love
affair avec doc gynéco vrai ou non c'est
parce qu'il agit lui il a dit on a fait
ce qu'on a voulu au milieu de 50 caméras
sans que les gens s'en rendent compte ça
c'est le cas maintenant parce que c'est
imaginer c'est endemol a l'occasion me
montrer cette séquence il ne rate pas
cette nuit s'était pas gêné deux ans
avant mais bon c'est vrai loana et jean
edouard et alors on a dit que vous étiez
la maîtresse de vladimir poutine
vrai ou pas et du cuir assez
sérieusement non sérieusement non vous
n'avez jamais été la maîtresse de
vladimir poutine
je sais pas est ce que malheureusement
heureusement non mais la dsi et la dsi
vous avez interrogé là-dessus
le contre-espionnage français vous
interrogez on interrogeait est-ce que
j'étais la représentante en france de
poutine veut pas est ce que je t'ai la
maîtresse bien on a dit que j'étais
végétarienne alors que je viens de
l'avion
il y avait eu bat fille parce que
j'étais sûr je marque et ben ça
s'appelle un automate et tu vois c'est
quand même la cajoler réseau on a dit
que vous apparteniez à la mafia russe
c'est pas vrai bien évidemment sinon je
pourrais dire que tous les allemands et
je pourrais dire que tous les allemands
sont masi tous les français sans les
maladies on a dit que j'étais une
espionne du kgb que finalement dans nice
people avec tous les micros toutes les
caméras n'étiez pas gêné ça c'est vrai
c'est une espionne végétarienne avec
vladimir poutine moi je comprends plus
rien
oui non si j'ai bien compris votre
question est ce que ça m'a gêné ou non
la présence des caméras ça ne me gêne
pas parce que je suis un habitué des
caméras pendant c'est parce que je
lancerai comme une animatrice quand je
travaille depuis longtemps
parce que c'est la guerre ce soir de
nécrophile maintenant on a dit qu'à six
mois après vous auriez pu être la
fiancée de paul loup sulitzer
je pense que on est des gens des
différentes générations
vous aimez pas quand le mec est plus âgé
j'aime quand le mec est plus intelligent
ouais c'est passé dans le bouquin ils
sont
ils sont plus âgés et n'a les mines a
remis une mare de2 tous ces ragots de
tous et en dit vous avez décidé d'écrire
un livre autobiographique qui s'appelle
cours camarade cours chez michel lafon
alors vous racontez votre votre enfance
ans en sibérie dans une ville qui
s'appelle akadem goro doc qu'un
la cité des savants alors dans vos
parents était chercheur vite privilégiez
vous aviez quand même droit à tout ça ça
n'a rien à voir avec la politique mais
c'est plutôt mes parents et l'endroit où
j'ai la chance de vivre cette cité des
savons des chaque voisin de palier et et
où le prix nobel de quelque chose au
l'académicien de quelque chose c'était
vraiment très très impressionnant et
très utile à n'importe qui alors non
mais sérieusement c'est une éducation
très stricte que celle d'elena lénine à
berne à la télé interdite
vous étiez obligés de lire marx engels
lénine pas le droit de lire agatha
christie ou d'humains maternelle
montaigne seneca ou chesterfield c'était
quand même un peu exagéré parce que moi
tu sais moi la culture
en effet j'ai adoré alexandre dubois
mais c'était nommé par mes parents parce
que c'était une littérature que mon
chien ming wang pour les serres pour le
cerveau est alors en juin c'est un jour
un jeu où vous apprenez la cdc le choc
c'est le choc que là elle apprend qu'en
france les seuls que qui a c'est devant
les cinémas etc et supermarchés se sont
plaints et et vous découvrirez ce moment
là effectivement l'ampleur du mensonge
c'est à dire l'urss en fait avait créé
un un monde en carton-pâte un petit peu
comme les façades de deux de potemkine
quand l'impératrice passé vous
connaissez ça lna absolument je me
rappelle d'un dan au voyage non mais
démissionne de la physique nucléaire
la première fois qu'il a visitées pour
un congrès des savants l'italie les
réunions en racontant qu'il a pleuré
le supermarché c'était impressionnant
quand gorbatchev fait son discours où il
annonce la fin de l'urss votre mère
pleure c'est pour dire comme
l'attachement de vos parents à à l'union
soviétique
il y avait plein de suicide parmi même
les agents de quai jobez ses horreurs
c'était une génération perdue les gens
arrêter toute leur vie pour les idéaux
de deux pays
ils ont protégé leur pays et d'un coup
il n'y a rien pour quoi ils ont consacré
l'on sorte alors non mais il faut
souligner quand même et cela tant
boucher un coin mon garçon elena est
arrivé vierge au mariage mais
lanta qui monta qui ne sait pas ce qu on
est acquis mais c'est beau moi je trouve
pourquoi c'est bien pourquoi ils s'en
vont rencontrer yves bény vous ne privez
pas prononcer son prénom
il est finalement mourir vous découvrez
qui a encore des classes sociales en
urss
parce que finalement vous vous êtes
d'une classe privilégiée évidemment vos
parents était chercheur vous arrivez
chez lui vous découvrez que finalement
les classes sociales n'ont pas été
abolie parce que ses parents ce sont des
ploucs un mon ex mari était temps d
enfant surdoué qui a ramassé partout
dans l'ex urss dans tout les coins au le
plus éloigné pour les mettre tous dans
l'académie gordon pour former le logis
de la nation de la nation dont on a été
aussi on faisait partie et c'est vrai
que ce genre de surdoué
bon ça dépend pas de classe ouais c'est
mais quand vous tombez jo des parents
alors là c'est le choc vous dites bon
alors c'est le même choc quand je tombe
dans les français dans le pays france de
la france et quand je vois autant des
stéréotypes de pêcher des russes ça m'a
fait l'effet de choc dans l'autre sens
un nom revient de russie sont aussi des
stéréotypes sur les français les
versements les russes adorent la france
pour les russes c'est que les gens
cultivés les gens qui ont de la culture
qui en qui on a envie d'apprendre le
français qui adore la que la culture
française la littérature française je
peux paraît même que n'importe quel
écolier russe si vous le prenez il va
vous citer beaucoup plus des écrivains
français que peut-être un écolier france
qu'ils étaient torturés se joue et non
les russes adorent plein de choses en
france votre cuisine les fromages lepage
la cosmétique décoratifs la menthe ou ce
que tout ce que le maire de ligue 1 j'ai
jamais entendu ces sources policières
cette caste vous pouvez revenir quand
vous voulez l'ena même si vous n'avez
pas de promotion on pouvait bien juste
pour le plaisir pour dire bonsoir vous
quittez yevgeny et vous devenez
mannequin à ce moment-là lna voilà il
alors vous avez effectivement une danse
qu'est ce qui se passe j'ai fait tomber
mon rideau c'est un happening je vais
ramasser ça y est
[Applaudissements]
samedi
c'est très très longtemps alors d'écrire
à la télé de demain qui rit on passera
au moment de vérité que laurent boyer
s'est passé sur la latte elena thierry
le goal et moi ça change quoi dire j'ai
dit thierry je crois que c'est le moment
de vérité alors vous trouvez que les
françaises sérieusement sont un petit
peu austère se sont pas très sexy en
fait un oui mais je trouve que les
français sont absolument sexy sauf que
j'ai une chose à reprocher enfin deux
françaises qui font pas autant d efforts
pour s'entretenir
mais je peux pas dire tout mais voilà
que les français se coupe les ongles
comme des écolières qu'elle s'habille en
noir qu'elle met des chaussures plates
qu'elles sont passées que s'ils ratent
qu'elles sont infléchies vous dites à
mon avis ils ont un peu moins enfin
maman sexy que c'est à dire ils font
exprès pour ne pas paraître le sexy mais
moi je pensais toujours que centre
s'occupait de son nom s'est pas séparée
de la boccia m
on est on est avec tout avec des même si
vous voulez avec mêmes bases
jean-paul ces moments sympas pour
jean-paul de dire ça je fais les efforts
mon nom certaines préfèrent ne pas
porter détail les talons haute
oui non mais vous avez un petit peu
raison moi je suis assez d'accord avec
vous non excusez-moi novo c'est tout
c'est pas pour la ramener mais on est
allé en russie d'elena renom n'a pas
croisé nous ne traductrice
je me presser
cela m'a fait très plaisir
sibérie
récemment notre travail à nous donner
envie de nous mettre les deux doigts
dans la bouche
la fête ouais bien alors on continue
donc vous quittez yevgeny vous devenez
mannequin vous créez votre société de
production de télé après je vais vite
chaud janvier édition à toutes les
chaînes
il l'a hélas ce qui se passe et la lna
et la d62 et la dalle et moi je suis
buffalo grill d'aller faire du skate non
de changer de sexe non pas alain et de
nous mais de loin pas le prononcer
cosmétologie figurative par téléphone
jean ben c'est pas d'aller d'aller en
france
non elle décide de ne couché qu'avec des
hommes riches et puissants c'est le
temps des essais mais alexandre le
propriétaire de l'usiné nucléaire
il a quitté sa femme et sa maîtresse
pour vous deux propriétaires du gène
nucléaire il avait dit ils avaient des
datchas dans la forêt sibérienne ces
privilégiés ou s'il y avait des
séquelles mais j'avais des peintures
mais c'est toucher radioactifs en mairie
non mais je comprends pas pourquoi
zidane dans cette émission pour sa part
bien au cou comme il faut j'adore
j'adore j'ai envie d'être chez moi pour
la regarder
alexandre à 6 e son seul crime est avec
eux ils étaient riches je m'excuse
j'admire votre professionnalisme
j'aime beaucoup ma femme et lui si on
met quoi qu'est ce qui se passe et non
non mais je pense que tu manges lna
c'est marcel béliveau
royan
son attaquant qui m'a appelé haha
oui me dire côtoya sera c'est sûr mais
surprise la série enfin l'accent
canadien qu'à la fin c'est incroyable
non mais c'est pas contre toi toi ton
boulot c'est devant seigneur nous c'est
de faire place aux jo on a autant de mal
bien que de comics là c'est déloyal
concert avec du foie gras pour toi assez
de kick ses deux ailes de l'avion j'ai
pas compris c'est quand même et oui
parce que c'est la portée du foie gras
et ont ils été pourri pour me faire
plaisir je veux apporter du foie gras
nord qui fait bien de parler de ça parce
qu'un jour j'ai rencontré hélène ségara
dans le train et elle était très très
faim elle disait ben oui à chaque fois
elle le prend très mal parce que
l'impression qu'on se fout de sa gueule
de semaine mehdi lui parce que quand
elle a croisé dans le train va encore me
pleurer même si tu le coupé au montage
pour la galerie qu aucun moment sont que
tu es sincère pour une fois excusez
hélène je te dis très sincèrement
alors elle je te le dis très sincèrement
par le magazine que des batteries mais
je te le dis très sincèrement h 30 au
coach un petit peu je te le dis très
sincèrement presse de faire la gaule la
faconde enfin sur foot et la larme à
l'oeil bouge rien bouche par le clan
voilà bougeries nantes en fait trop le
vis très sincèrement elle a le mot est
peut-être j'aime ton foie gras pourri
message de charles aznavour qui veut
racheter les droits de la chance
alors on continue
elena dans la déconne et moi c'est
souvent sans travail tous les dons
sentons bien mais nous ici j'avais rien
contre moi nous demander comme un frère
pour moi sur la bouche
je préfère que comment tu me met votre
télé
je nie mieux que tu m'embrasses quartier
pue de la gueule on peut lire cette
histoire depuis dans la zi béatrice
m'enfin on peut toujours rien n'empêche
que le bouquin raconte très très bien la
vie d'elena
ouais
ça vaut pour comment les cdc
mes amis
c'est lui
m
alors on peut s'excuser
on est en fait de rapport elle en a vu
d'autres en ldc est ce qu'on peut avoir
le baiser russe n'a pas vu dans ces
brasiers tropicale chez nous c'est
combien dans les fesses je me suis la
plus la moldau des flèches sacs à dos
le moteur c'est quand on va voir si les
navettes capables de s'acclimater en
france lé kapab à l'axé s'acclimater en
france on va faire l'interview si ce
sondage
[Musique]
lna non là je vous demande de vous
concentrer un petit peu parce que je
vous demande de vous arrêter
c'est un test donc je vous posais des
questions et on va voir si vous
correspondez à la moyenne des françaises
on va voir si vous êtes une française
désormais alors attention
est ce que vous préférez faire l'amour
le matin au réveil ou le soir au coucher
le matin le soir le soir et en nocturne
plutôt comme 62% des francaise voila
vous êtes
70% j'espère faire l'amour le soir avant
de s'endormir voilà voilà
c'est votre cas non mais moi j'ai fait
l'amour au réveil est gelée cassé
quelque 1 38 % des jeunes vous êtes
casse alors là c'est intéressant
faire l'amour elena dans le noir oui je
pense que c'est plutôt timide je préfère
d'accord comme 56% des français soit la
plaisir est là et tu ne devrais
française à texte intéressant est ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour faire l'amour où
il veut quand il veut où ils veulent
quand ils veulent
on va où il veut quand il veut
je pense pas tout comme les françaises
66 % des françaises refusent de le faire
l'amour quand je veux
je le veux
françaises sont des mythomanes ouais
parce que 34 qui sont d'accord pour
faire l'amour où il veut quand il
comment ça se fait qu'on tape tout le
temps dans les 34 ses côtés
est ce que vous faites l'amour la
première fois le premier soir la
première rencontre de suite là ce soir
là après l'émission jeu pour moi l'amour
c'est quelque chose qui se passe dans la
tête dans les coeurs mais c'est par elle
et elle est comme là il n'y a que 12 %
des françaises qui baisent le premier
soir on les amène vous êtes une vraie
française va me donner le certificat de
la naturalisation
bien sûr je vous donne tout tiens tu as
peu 39 % des françaises refusent la
fellation et vous le premier sera donc
m'expliquer ce que cela veut dire la
fellation alors proches qu'elle sache
dire cosmétiques concupiscent fellation
c'est le français à l'âge de 5 ans à
l'école maternelle en sibérie cinq ans
déjà lui la prendre
tu verrais pas des nations alain chabat
et je trouve froid relance obama
effectivement je suis assez d'accord
avec michael mais je vais tout de même
que voilà la scène où tu vois ma vie
ceci est une tête a pas quelque part
dans la tête il y a une bouche je sais
c'est étonnant mais un oeil qu'on se
repère mais là quand on perd et parce
que non même temps la serbe a passé ses
barbecues sexy dance machine attendez
attendez donc dosettes
vous êtes est ce que vous êtes comme 39%
des français vous refusez je vous
attends je préfère cunnilingus ya rien à
dire alors
en attendant tony weeks non 71 % des
françaises seraient choqués si un couple
d'amis leur proposer d'aller dans un
club échangiste
mais je comprends ouais c'est pas des
familles dans ce cas il faudra qu'on
discute qu'est ce que c'est à dire le en
fidélité leur fidélité et c'est sûrement
complexe les instituts travail sur cette
problème je pense pas qu'on va trouver
la solution s'est effectué lui leur
demande est ce que tu veux coucher avec
90 répondent les uns étaient sûrs
m c'est la cité des savants oui enfin
alors dernière question êtes vous prête
à devenir l'esclave sexuelle de votre
mec là maintenant j'ai le chiffre des
françaises c'est pas beaucoup un peu
dire je pense que c'est possible qu'une
femme tombe tellement amoureuse d'un
homme qu'ils deviennent dépendantes de
lui dans le domaine sexuel
absolument mais je pense que si on part
c'est formidable de l'autre parent c'est
comme tout les genres de dépendance
c'est quand même très difficile à vivre
vachement bien oui mais c'est sa
question et est longue
non mais tu lui poses des questions qu
intellectuel
lors qu'il faut
et
c'est tout
sur lui
govou seul
[Musique]
j'accueille ma tante chanel bouras
bon michael on va parler de choses
sérieuses là on va parler du voile
d'accord et ben ali
aulas
c'est pour les gens qui voudraient de
régler leur poste
c'est un concours sans toiture certaines
fois mais bon vous savez quoi faire face
à une coiffeuse donateurs bd met en
péril parce que mireille tulle et ussel
embrasser la russe non j'ai pas bien
compris les essais le premier soir non
plus ce que tu fais des trucs à
trottiner vous proposer à toi et ton
mari d'aller dans un club échangiste
cuir et mireille parle-nous d'alexandre
un peu ce milliardaire russe
j'avais beaucoup d'un toit dans la forêt
sibérienne c'est bien mais c'est pas ce
même service normal trop
une première
j'admire elle va s'imposer dans cette
émission comme une mascotte bouras donc
jamais le noise vous étiez samedi
dernier à la manif contre la loi sur le
voile à l'école car vous êtes contre il
faut bien le dire vous dit si on exclut
ces jeunes filles voilées de l'école
laïque
elles vont devenir encore moins laïque
est effectivement sur les renvoyer chez
elles elles vont être encore plus
musulmane disons je crois que il faut
laisser la liberté à chacun il ya qu'en
france en ce moment où on pose toutes
ces questions moi qui ai l'habitude de
voyager par le sport ou par autres
j'entends il y a qu'en france où
j'entends ces choses là maintenant aussi
j'aimerais expliquer aux gens que j'ai
participé à cette manifestion cette
manifestation en tant qu'individu la
société civile parce que je suis quand
j'entends des choses qui me choque c'est
un peu mais ni temps depuis que je suis
enfant et quand il ya des choses qui me
choquent la preuve
enfin quand y'a eu l'open qui est passé
second tour on s'est manifestée
puisqu'il y avait un acteur une personne
raciste qui allait passer au feu enfin
bref l'essentiel ce sera du voile
d'accord mais tu ne parles pas de
générique
comment la chose la plus importante
c'est le savoir et la connaissance
donc à partir du moment où tu enlèves
les gens l'école c'est à dire que même
si on est dans l'erreur
ouais tu vas l'école était dans l'erreur
bon on t'a vous allez etc
tu vois des colts parents soient
intégrés sous je ne sais pas tu vas
l'école mais s'ils ont pu sont enlève de
ça on t'enlève l'école pour pouvoir te
mélanger et échanger avec des ouf comme
cela enfin de partout et que tu peux tu
ouvrir ou à prendre
ben tu vas tu vas donc je vois pas où
c'est que tu peux tu vas devenir encore
plus renfermés sur tout simplement
fondamentale pour moi la chose la plus
importante c'est de l'accès au savoir et
de la connaissance
alors
vous dites que finalement le port du
voile peut effectivement peut-être
perturber la scolarité mais moins qu'un
string qui dépasse d'un jean non je
plaisante est pas ce que j'ai entendu
des gamins diabaté à la télé et ça
m'avait fait rire qui disait que un peu
comme dans son style disait qu'ils
étaient venus des rangs dérangé par un
string quand il était à l'école qui
dépassait du jeans que par un foulard
l'afrique le foulard personnes à calcul
alors que la file quand on glass et un
bon qu est l axe le sprinter plus des
concentre r ça que par le truc cool
quand même vous allez vous êtes ce que
vous êtes contre le port du string à
l'école non non je suis pas pour moi
chacun fait ce qu'il veut pour le pont
des doors même temps djamel vous vous
jugé que cette loi faisait nos folles
imbécile et raciste et oui le
gouvernement est en train d'installer
l'islamophobie dans ce pays
la preuve hier ils ont commencé à dire
que la barbe il fallait pas la barbe
aussi et le bandana elle bandana non
mais ils viennent de plus en plus
violent à sanaa alors vous étiez à cette
manifestation donc samedi le le problème
c'est que d'abord c'est bon pour le pen
c'est à dire que quand les français
voient au journal télévisé tous et tous
ces gens qu'il chérit vous pensez bien
que ça va faire des voix en plus pour le
pen sur une prestation vous savez très
bien et l'autre problème c'est aussi que
beaucoup de députés de droite à
commencer par balladur qui étaient
d'accord pour ne pas voter la loi il
disait finalement oui cette fois ça sert
à rien depuis la manifestation de samedi
ont changé la ville ont envie de la
beauté donc je vous pensais pas que ce
genre de manifestation
à quelques mois des élections peut
finalement de provoquer un raidissement
de la classe politique française
moi je pense oui ouais ouais je pense
moi je pense que malgré tout gérer la
manif
je pense que le grand gagnant pas de la
manif parce que ya pas que ça fait ça
fait quelques temps quand même que
l'événement
ouais que couvre couvre les médias quoi
donc c'est pas une question de manille
faux pas de manif ça depuis très
longtemps on en parle
maintenant je pense que cette politique
la mènera alors je crois que c'est pas
bon à cette manifestation il avait aussi
mohamed latrèche du pmf le parti des
musulmans de france alors lui les
antisionistes bon ça c'est son droit
il est aussi terriblement antisémite il
est l'éditeur du manifeste judéo nazis
d'ariel sharon qui est une vraie fausse
interview du premier ministre d'israël
il était à la tribune avec serge thion
qui était un négationniste très connu et
il a dit en parlant de serge thion je
suis très content et fier de le
connaître est ce que à un moment
finalement même si vous n'étiez pas
derrière lui on a bien compris mais est
ce qu'à un moment le fait finalement de
manifester avec quelqu'un comme la
trèche c'est pas dangereux
maintenant mais moi comme je dis c'est
un ami sic au début qui est venu dans
mon salon de thé qui me diront
manifestent samedi
jeudi pour ce contre cette loi je dis
bah écoute c'est super moi aussi je suis
contre cette loi là et après dans les
médias j'entendais tous les jours comme
quoi il y avait une espèce de groupe
enfin participer mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc là personne ne le
connaît on ne connaît même pas et non je
suis allé en tant qu'observateur pour
montrer que j'étais contre 7 la 9e et
10e suis d'aucune mouvance vous l'avez
déclaré l'intéressé planifie quand j'ai
entendu parler
cette personne veut se sauver ouais
ouais mais c'est vrai qu'à cette manif
on aurait préféré voir monseigneur
lustiger où le drame ainsi ce truc c'est
moi ça j'ai cru qu'il avait ça moi j'ai
cru qu'ils avaient tout le monde quoi
c'est quand même une loi raciste quoi
vous vous savez quand même que vous êtes
en train de devenir le porte parole des
musulmans
il en faudra bien mais dans tous les
pays du monde y ait des gens qui sont un
moment porté porté sur le 200 c'est que
les gens les des gens qui n'osent pas
parler et moi ça va chier quoi y'a des
gens qui pensent qu'à leur business tu
vois alors que un moment donné on se
fait insulter tout le temps j'ai ramené
un petit manifeste ici tous les jours tu
vois où on est quand même des musulmans
chacun assad et la salinité tu vas bien
sûr et puis un proverbe qui dit va
kherrata dignité en enfer s'il le faut
ils refusent de l'humiliation même au
paradis
ouais qui est de moutanabi et quand tu
entends un mec comme claude imbert clou
d'un maire qui dit je suis un peu
islamophobe
ça ne me gêne pas de le dire j'ai le
droit de penser que l'islam
je dis bien l'islam je ne parle même pas
des islamistes apporte une certaine
débilité qui en effet me rends
islamophobe et ça c'est un berck en
temps quand tu entends matérialiste au
journal le point le point mais bien sûr
quand on tend houellebecq qui dit la
religion à wahlberg la religion la plus
con c'est quand même l'islam quand on
dit le coran en effondré il faut
admettre une chose mais je veux dire moi
je suis catholique mais en même temps en
france de tous temps il ya des gens
confié sur la religion catholique et on
a appris à vivre avec ça fait partie de
la démocratie ça non ouais ça fait
partie de la nuit dessus mais je veux
dire quand je vois le pain aux guignols
qui prend de la coke par exemple ça me
gêne mais voilà c'est comme ça ils ont
le droit de le faire un moment mais je
dis pas qu'on n'a pas droit de faire
mais de dire des conneries concerne un
ministre quand et d'économie qui
plaisantent là-dessus encore vous est
compréhensible mais quand c'est un
ministre qui dit xavier darcos qui dit
content quand on n'aime pas la
république française on va ailleurs à la
france aimez là ou quittez là c'est à
dire que quand t'es pas content je peux
vous dire que c'est toi
mais ce qui s'est passé que ces gens
sont français je sais le problème c'est
qu'on n'accepte pas à la preuve
la preuve c'est que comment un ministre
le ministre le premier ministre de
l'intérieur
sarkozy qui soit disant pas de
république nicolas decamps lutter contre
la loi et finalement il s'est rallié
s'il va demander ça veut dire qu'il va
demander son avis à l'étranger ouais
c'est à dire qu'il va arriver arriva en
egypte pour demander à soi disant chef
ou un savant religieux pour le dire est
ce que j'ai le droit quand même de faire
ça ça veut dire qu il alors que c'est un
problème franco français
enfin c'est bien un peu le cas de
prendre la vie des des sommités
musulmanes dans le monde c'est une lutte
et on le connaît pas
y'a pas de sommités c'est à dire ça
c'est un problème franco français je
vois pas pourquoi ça veut dire que nous
acceptons pas encore compris qu'on n'ait
pas accepté comme français si l'enfant
c'est ça le problème
mais il ya un autre qui est important
s'il te plait je devrais te dire c'est
moi j'ai fait les jeux olympiques tu vas
j'ai rapporté des médailles pour la
france et pour il ya des valeurs que
j'ai représenté
mais ces valeurs là quand j'ai lu cet
article à cette déclaration c'est ça que
j'ai défendue tu vois alors j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous lire cette déclaration
qui dit toute déclaration qui djamel des
glaçons des droits universels des droits
de l'homme basé chez claire c'est à dire
que même les lois qu'on fait les
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme c'est au dessus c'est vrai
d'accord donc il faut bien écouter je la
porte l'attention de hao gens tu vas de
bien écouter cette déclaration qui dit
toute personne a droit à la liberté de
pensée de conscience et de religion ce
droit implique la liberté de manifester
sa religion ou sa conviction seule ou en
commun tant en public qu'en privé par le
lez par l'enseignement les pratiques le
culte et l'accomplissement des rites
c'est clair non donc je sais pas ce
qu'on essaie en fait ça c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt la france a beaucoup
de problèmes en ce moment au niveau
chômage au niveau il ya 38 ans que dans
les sociétés il ya un moment il ya plein
de problèmes sauf qu'on met sur
l'histoire du voile ça va à cacher tous
les problèmes qu'on a un peu tu penses
c'est un peu comme ces chaussures de
roland dumas sur l' affaire des frégates
de taïwan coneway je n'ai pas bien son
histoire
la voiture corrélation non mais bon tu
va donc continuer à manifester pour
tulle a mieux fait que je continue à
dire ma vérité tout le temps mais
maintenant on va essayer de ne pas se
faire piéger par certains mais c'est
clair que non parce que si c'est si ça
avait été les juifs qui m'appelle ekindi
djamel on va enlever notre jeu mais avec
eux mais manifestèrent bien merci djamel
on a parlé du voile mais cette loi met
en cause une autre catégorie de la
population française ce sont les sticks
voici man preet singh
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue même preet singh dans
tout le monde en parle l'émission où
tout le monde parle
la preuve bonsoir donc il ya 7000 sic en
france surtout des gens qui sont des
réfugiés victimes de la répression dont
les cycles sont victimes en inde
et puisque les six veulent
l'indépendance du calice temps donc
effectivement ça pose des problèmes avec
avec l'inde
alors le cyclisme qu'est ce que le
cyclisme c'est une des quatre grandes
religions de l'inde
ainsi nos religions monothéistes qui
rejette toutes les pratiques hindous
croyance des classes pendant plusieurs
dieux les castes la crémation des veuves
le mariage des enfants la claustration
des femmes etc
donc c'est une religion 10 hakim roule
oui c'est une agent beaucoup beaucoup
plus cool donc les idéaux des cycles
sont assez simple c'est méditer
travailler et partage et voilà c'est
vraiment la morale de votre religion
les femmes sont les égales des hommes
dans le cyclisme il n'y a pas de
supériorité
pas de tabac pas d'alcool un petit peu
comme dans la religion musulmane on est
alors les six que ne se coupe pas les
cheveux ni la barbe sans respect sans
respect de la nature
on est sur terre on a on a eu la barbe
on a eu les cheveux on ne va pas donner
une paire de ciseaux avec un donc la
base de la religion et qu'on protège
voilà on regarde ce que nous a donné la
nature et les femmes chez vous portent
la même chose vous apporte la même chose
donc nous jouerons aussi les hommes et
les femmes portent sur ben voilà et donc
effectivement ce turban vous refusé de
l'enlever pour vous cette loi était
absolument inacceptable et d'ailleurs
fait une lettre à jacques chirac en
disant que le turban n'est pas chez vous
un signe de fondamentalisme ou
d'intégrisme alors évidemment après on
cherche des solutions lors luc ferry qui
a toujours de bonnes idées qui a trouvé
l'idée du bandana de la barre dans ce
cas des vraies idées
ville à proposer ce qu'il appelle le
turban invisible à luc ferry a inventé
le turban invisible c'est à dire c'est
un poil c'est juste c'est un fils et un
ca petit filet que vous mettriez sens
que je veux c'est ridicule pour aller à
l'école mais vous auriez un petit filet
qu'on ne verrait pas qu'ils tiendraient
vos cheveux enfin on est vraiment en
même temps on est dans le bonheur c'est
pour montrer que le pari est la capitale
de la mode
nouvelle mode donc luc ferry ce qu'il
aimerait si vous ayez un fil invisible
et que vous radier votre barbe puisque
maintenant d'après ce qu'ils disent la
barbe est aussi un signe ainsi
d'intégrisme pour assurer luc ferry le
raser sa barbe avec le rasoir invisible
alors
bon à savoir quand même pour les
politiques c'est que le turban vous dit
c'est pas comme une croix cc clôture
m'en fait partie de notre corps sans
turban on n'est plus des sikhs
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très de
très très importante ne s'est pas juste
décoratifs et ses amis fichés chez les
ch et les cycles le turban gars c'est
parce qu'il faut pas se couper les
cheveux parce que dieu voulait cacher
voilà c'est pour les cacher on les cache
pas on est protégé
voilà d'accord c'est une sorte en 1 de
la personne qui porte le turbo est une
personne respectée donc notre no no no
de base de lait base de la religion et
qu'on respecte toutes les religions et
tous les toutes les personnes qu'il ya
dans le monde que ce soit des personnes
qui sont croyants ou non croyants
donc c'est un signe de respect kaunas un
signe de dignité donc toucher ou offert
enlever le turban dans le monde entier
est une sorte d' insulte alors vous
dites sans turban donc on n'est plus des
cycles oui c'est un truc sacré le turban
c'est pas comme un chapeau ou une
casquette quoi c'est vraiment incroyable
moi je me porte 24 heures sur 24 devant
vous dormez avec je dors avec je
l'enlève juste pour me laver les cheveux
ou pour penne mes cheveux donc et il
n'est pas loin de moi il reste à côté de
moi et je leur porte directeur chirac
jacques chirac a besoin d'un public a
dit la laïcité n'est pas négociable
et vous vous dites notre foi non plus
voilà vous dirai non écossais a besoin
négociable et vous dit que finalement ça
s'est vu de galway
c'est grave en tous les cas pas ce que
vous dites que si vous étiez obligés
d'enlever votre turban pour aller à
l'école vous arrêteriez d'aller à
l'école vous personnellement et là on
rejoint ce que disait djamel bouras tout
à l'heure c'est à dire que donc en
interdisant aux gens l'accès à l'école
publique
finalement les renferme dans leur ghetto
donc c'est une ghettoïsation finalement
laura droit au communautarisme
faire de l'anti communautarisme on y va
à droite directement
là on est là on ensemble les communautés
son ensemble moi je connais beaucoup de
bruit personnes d'autres communautés on
a grandi ensemble
ben on arrivé à ce point là c'est que si
on fait des écoles séparées on se casse
entre nous laisse rien entre nous c'est
quelque chose d'inadmissible quoi vous
êtes pour l'école publique en fait moi
pour l'instant je on a pas de problème
nous classique en majorité nous avons
pas de problème à l'école nous portons
nos turban à l'école est une sorte de
tolérance mais on a peur pour la suite
ouais que cette loi soit votée l'année
prochaine là ça nous vos problèmes
sauf là où ça peut gêner peut-être sait
si un élève derrière voit moins bien
gênante active et peut-être de
s'organiser
non là il ya un problème par exemple
souvent les les musulmans intégristes
ça commence par le voile puis après ils
disent on veut plus participer aux cours
de gym on va plus participer aux cours
de biologie on va plus participer aux
cours d'histoire géo donc ça commence à
poser des problèmes effectivement bon
vous vous acceptez les cours d'histoire
géo la gym la biologie oui vous oubliez
pas de problème à ce genre de refus en
plus là dessus et derrière quoi il
derrière 24 ans qu'à chaque
établissement est généralisée des
établissements
chaque appartement j'ai entendu ces
histoires et puis après c'est le docteur
qui a fait un certificat d'après cette
problème être le docteur calmette
certificat tu vois c'est pas de là qu'on
va faire une loi pour interdire ce
qu'ils veulent vraiment le maître parce
que c'est leur conviction etc on va pas
rentrer dans leurs pensées dans dans
leur intérieur
toute la classe à part
c'est ce qui se passait avant et c'était
pas bien ça apparemment non puisque il
faut une loi
alain me permettre moi j'suis un peu
david tout le monde bien merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu témoigner et à bientôt
on suivra ce qui se passera pour les
sites vous savez que vous savez qu'à
tout le monde en parle
on a été les premiers c'est incroyable
tout bon d'accord il s'est invité en
tchétchène c'est qu'elle ait jamais eu
de titre chaîne de la télévision jusqu'à
ce qu'on la vit bien on est les premiers
à lithaire un sikh et on vous remercie
beaucoup d'être venu
[Musique]
et
ouais
je veux
arrêts de jeu
te plaît
normand jardin
voici benjamin biolay
soit
ça barde les bons choix alors on m'avait
dit une fois benjamin josé l'interview
technicolor vous avez dit ce qui peut me
rendre rouge de honte si d'être mal
coiffée et qu'on me fasse des réflexions
sur ma coiffure voilà qui s'y colle un
peu déçu quand vous mettez pas assure
benjamin c'est pas là mon éducation je
vais fonctionner c'est trop bien
benjamin ça va ça va je vous fais un
compliment vous êtes le wonderboy de la
pop française et depuis est depuis
salvador tout le monde veut bosser avec
vous souvent des gens âgés d'ailleurs
juliette gréco valérie lagrange
françoise hardy il faut dire aussi
qu'ils aillent vers nova et nadia soeur
donc finalement ces équilibres alors
faut dire qu'effectivement vous êtes
très doué il est doué ce garçon qui se
disent malgré une enfance assez modeste
avec un père agent de maîtrise à la nef
et une mère femme au foyer vous
grandissez dans un hlm mais vous avez
une éducation culturelle qui est très
bourgeoise juin bizarrement la
bourgeoisie enfin de famille de mon père
voilà alors vous êtes au violon à cinq
ans mais pourquoi ils avaient acheté des
chaussures art aujourd'hui ma fille il
est au violon à cinq ans et puis alors
après donc c'est bien violent parce que
dans le nord chez les gens modestes si
tu veux le 11 bat du viol orange ou du
des cuivres ont en général des pauvres
on joue de la trompette
des casseroles bien sûr bah ouais bah
c'est moins cher sais tu savais pas ça
ne s'est pas faite dans qu'au début il
est dans le violon ce qui est assez
étonnant compte tenu de ses origines
cieux et après il ya le tubiste qui
meurt et vous vous retrouvez à ces
terribles en train de jouer du tuba
avait dit c'est très pénible en finale
c'est très pénible parce que par exemple
dans un orchestre ont joué une note
toutes les 20 minutes qu'il ya des fois
mais c'est également vers l'équipe de
fermer mais qu'ils écoutent la radio 1
j'écoute le multiplex avec eux j'ai fait
comme les écoutes et j'aime ça tourne au
jeu lui même quand tu vois ce que tu
sais pas c'est quand tu vois un énorme
hors caisse comme ça alors
donc comme je les dis enfance musical
vous avez l'oreille absolue
je lis ça je veux tant mieux pour vous
parce que vous trouviez ça pénible s'est
quant à elle l'oreille absolue alors la
lutte chantant
aujourd'hui il avait 20 sur verdict et
mélodique cirque eu l'oreille absolue
entente où tu entends toutes les [ __ ]
de nature un trait de violon au
cinquième rang tu l'entends
c'est que j'ai dit est ce que vous avez
pensé qu'une somme un an
le chant c'est la classe bon alors on
écoute ça ouais ça sorte de cithare et
entendez ici et pourrait peser sur
l'oreille absolue alors tué par chance
c'est une chance mais c'est en fait ce
que m'a expliqué ce matin l'intéressé
mickeal parce que je l'aurais que barnes
et qu'elena en a marre d'être à côté de
laurent d'ombré qui fait le succès mikel
michael l'oreille absolue tu entends
toutes les notes et alors il ya un autre
truc que je savais pas c'est l'oreille
harmonique et ja riise face alors
heureuse gentil harrison avait l'oreille
harmonique c'est à dire que george
harrison il fait partie des gens qui
entendent tous les accords c'est
formidable c'est le daily nk stone qui
avait sept capes
c'est ça que voudriez avoir l'oreille
harmonix est votre rêve en fait c'est
mon rêve vous avez un peu non en plus
c'est votre travail pour les autres vous
devez écouter non en plus de votre
travail pour les autres vous faites vos
albums et là une influence majeure c'est
mélodie nelson chaque banque vous étiez
petit nous avions entendu ce concept
album de serge gainsbourg
j'aimerais beaucoup influencé devrait
sortir un premier album qui s'appelle un
double qui s'appelait rose kennedy 1 qui
était consacrée à la famille à la
famille kennedy d'umbro d'être un roman
très romancé et aujourd'hui vous sorti
donc négatif qui est un double cd le
single en promo s'appelle je ne t'ai pas
aimé
j'aime le son
[Musique]
je
ce que tout
tout
non
sous des rangs
des fois je vous
j'étais
monsieur
naissance
j'ai juste retour
joue
se creuse à l'égout
[Musique]
benjamin mieux les jeunes étaient basés
mais extrait de son nouvel album qui
s'appelle négative en duo avec carat
mastroianni on avait déjà entendu
d'ailleurs dans un album de doc gynéco
il s'appelle quality street et la
chanson s'appelait trop jeune policier
doc gynéco gens qu'on s'est parlé
d'accord lui aussi oui alors je vais
écrire des chansons pour votre épouse de
chiara mastroianni moi je pense soin de
lui faire un petit album un petit sympa
alors vous dites quand vous parlez de
votre couple avec chiara mastroianni
on n'est pas un couple public le seul
truc c'est drôle seul truc qu'on allait
ensemble c'est le mariage c'est vrai
c'est vrai d'ailleurs là vous êtes sans
elle ce soir
absolument c'est sûr sur six est dans la
loge on a fait venir
alors comment vont les belle-mère
catherine deneuve justement est vrai
très bien elle va très bien est-ce que
vous déjeuner chez elle le dimanche à
midi ça peut arriver et des paupières
qu'on m'a dit ça vous arrive mais des
fois vous trouvez des excuses pour pas y
aller à ce déjeuner du dimanche n'ont
donc vous y allez ça vous plaît d'y
aller bouffer chez votre belle d'âge ça
vous plaît ah ouais ben j'en gardais
drucker ensemble absolument
vous lui avez offert quoi pendrel a je
sais plus et vous en verrez plus elle
vous a offert quoi elle sa fille c'est
pas mal un cendrier en forme de concours
ça lui plaît catherine deneuve d'être
grand mère
ouais mais beaucoup oui c'est marrant ça
et je leur dis sans vous aimeriez que
chiara mastroianni sa fille lui
ressemble si ça arrive pas me plaindre
je dis rien je pose des questions en
moins
c'est ça ou gloria lasso faut choisir
j'aimerais beaucoup ce cas là est ce que
vous l'avez du nu dans belle de jour
katherine dana reeve est belle de jour
qu'elle va % des français tu feras un
plan à trois essais de la réplication et
comme tu peu prétentieux bah oui on m'a
dit non non mais pas quand il va chez
catherine on m'a dit un sur le parquet
vous savez ça au lieu ce schisme
ouais c'est javier mas
[Musique]
une partie des vagues c'est quoi ce
alors si les accords scélérats scène
comme on en trouve on a fait de partir à
la neige
c'est quoi
sinon ça
des filles à périlleuse
on sent encore le neuf
[ __ ]
oui
g
c'est grave
on prend le but
c'est au tour
[Musique]
on les défauts en effet
mes garçons
[Musique]
les clubs et
la barre où j
à vue ils sont par hull où mes potes
elle sent super tes posts et un forfait
c'est satan brune est donc grave je vais
où
il faut laisser chaque mairie je suis
encore plus simple que tout est donc
rentré alors benjamin jama violées donc
vous avez la réputation d'être un petit
peu un petit peu snob comme ça un petit
peu prétentieux parce que je suis un peu
timide et je fais pas les chansons très
amusante
n'est ce pas une attitude que vous avez
aussi un petit peu comme ça je sais pas
si pièces de votre côté émotif qui vous
rend un peu distant on a l'impression
vous méprisez un peu les gens c'est vrai
nom si je prends des médicaments avant
les émissions d'abord jauge pas on se
dit il avec la fille de donna avec ma
fille de mastroianni
ça a marché maintenant donc non il ya un
autre truc qui courent sur vous aussi je
préfère qu'on en parle clairement
benjamin rendez vous avez une carte du
parti socialiste j'avais j'avais je
voulais plus c'est toi c'est moi
vous l'avez garder la carte pass grl et
avec collector les plats qu'ils ont peut
pas la déchirure vous l'avez garder non
bien sûr
vous êtes quand même un peu snob parce
que vous allez écrire un roman comme par
hasard c'est l'année rêve quand même pas
vraiment j'adorerais mais c'est pas du
tout à un rythme donc finalement vous
êtes sympas ils faire sympa bien alors
vous êtes vous êtes un excellent
songwriter vous écrivez les paroles vous
écrivez les musiques
donc on va vous faire une interview à
quoi ça rime
[Musique]
benjamin biolay si je vous demande de
faire une rime sur sarkozy ça suffit
j'ose pas sa fille revient au jeu star
revient hollande trop loin au moins la
rue hantz et les autres pays du fromage
quoi pays du sushi une rime sur chirac
arnaque aia voilà une rime sur kara
adroit l'italien c'est vrai dolce vita
une chose de neuf
sa vie son oeuvre enfin anna votre
petite fille à papa papa salvador queen
on va dire oui au quirinal la plus
grande fan ouais bénabar couillon c'est
bonnard vincent delerm en bons termes
laurent baffie j'aime bien son côté aux
logs en zoologie zoophilie on n'a été
tiré a redit son bras c'est le patron
oh
benjamin biolay
voilà le sénat
sa peine est
le cv
[Musique]
est-ce que manet hip hop venir pour me
mais pousse t un petit peu avant
l'interview web
[Musique]
je
et ça marche
et
mais
m
[Musique]
et maintenant je vante d'être un petit
peu concentré on accueille quelqu'un qui
a écrit un livre bouleversant réellement
bouleversant j'accueille christophe
tison
[Musique]
christophe tison bonsoir comme si
souvent djamel bouras elena lenina
benjamin biolay jean paul rouve michaël
youn
alain chabat laurent baffie physique
vote libre et est bouleversant c'est
vrai que ça faisait longtemps que
j'avais pas lu un truc aussi aussi fort
ça s'appelle il m'aimait essai publié
chez grasset alors d'abord on va dire
qui vous êtes avait 42 ans
vous êtes rédac chef au service culture
à canal+ et à itélévision et vous avez
déjà publié deux bouquins la drogue
expliquer aux parents chez balland il ya
deux clics périence oui je sais que nos
enfants aient l'air dû vite
toujours chez mal an mais alors on
revient il m'aimait il
c'est un adulte qui était amoureux de
l'enfant que vous étiez et le livre
raconte comment son amour parce que
c'était de l'amour comment son amant
vous a détruit oui oui c'est vrai alors
comme le fait remarquer notre ami
frédéric beigbeder dans voici
d'habitude la littérature abordé le
sujet de la de la pédophilie par l'angle
du narrateur pédophile c'est nabokov
dans le lit tu as et rose bonbon c'est
il entrerait dans la légende et en
général quand c'est des victimes qui
témoigne c'est plutôt des témoignages
assez moureaux assez vertueux est là
pour la première fois c'est toujours
beigbeder qui parlent ils viti l'on ose
dire oui les enfants sont attirés par
les adultes
idem quand les cajole voilà évidemment
le ska de très nouveau et à la fois de
très de très choquant mais de très vrai
dans votre livre c'est qu'en fait
l'enfant que vous étiez aimé
je dirai pas son bourreau enfin aimer
son amant d'une certaine façon il était
attiré par lui si oui c'est un peu ça
c'est un peu le syndrome de stockholm où
c'est
c'est quand un adulte prends soin de toi
finalement tulle m quoi il ya un truc un
truc très fort ouais il remplace ton
père est en place ta mère et puis et
puis finalement ben tu pues ne peux pas
t'empêcher de l'aimer jusqu'au moment où
vient le soir nous te retrouves dans le
lit avec lui ou là c'est horrible ouais
alors vous dit j'aurais dû refuser d'y
aller et pourtant c'est bien moi qui
retourner le voir c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il vous embrassez vous
cajoler il vous prodiguer de l'amour il
s'intéressait à vous et vous étiez d'une
certaine façon en tiré par lui pour dire
les choses crûment
bah oui il avait une énorme un énorme
sexe et puis moi j'étais tout petit j'ai
eu moi j'ai une fille qui a 9 ans ça a
commencé quand j'avais 9 ans je me dis
mais qu'est ce que ces petits quoi c'est
hallucinant et et this et je n'arrive
pas je n'arrive pas à m'y faire et bon
finalement c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'il m'est même cas je lai
et finalement il me faisait mal ouais
j'ai bien dans le livre c'est vraiment
très étonnant et très choquant moi j'ai
eu vraiment du mal car j'ai du mal à
lire à lille mais là vraiment c'est très
fort ce qui est terrible
ce qui est terrible dans le book cette
ambivalence est à dire que celui qui
vous fait le plus de mal est également
celui qui vous fait le plus de bien une
certaine façon ouais c'est vrai nom
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'était un
type génial parce que je vais pas faire
ma g pas faire son apologie aujourd'hui
mais c'était quand même un type génial
parce que il me faisait lire il faisait
il faisait lire boris vian il faisait
lire sartre etc
des lectures que j'aurais jamais eu si
j'avais été sans lui il me projetait des
films
j'allais dans des cinémas de ligny vous
emmener pas omis le décaméron il
projetait il me projetais caisse il me
projetais d'aider tout tout tout les
lauzes et et il était incroyable avec
moi
vraiment il était incroyable de d'amour
de tendresse de bon et le problème c'est
que après je le paye est quoi ouais et
billie jean ou alors c'est certain mais
je pense fortement à chaque fois ils
jouent à michael jackson j'y pense c'est
sûr il faut dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs que cette histoire se
passe quand même aux pires moments de
l'époque baba cool post-soixante-huitard
d'accès l'époque la sexualité n'a pas de
règles piles et les drogues partout sur
votre mère fumer des pétards devant vous
c'était l'époque de la permissivité une
époque assez libertaire naturiste les
enfants sont livrés à eux-mêmes donc
ouais mais c'était en même temps c'était
une époque gène hier c'était absolument
génial
moi j'adorais je me trouvais dans une
petite ville dans une espèce de traction
avant vert pomme et cetera avec des mecs
avec des cheveux longs temps réel tout
c'était génial parce que tous les gens
de la ville
c'était à beaune en bourgogne
ne pas dire le nom de la ville et puis
tous les gens d'avis disait mais qui
sait c'est horrible leap x clara et moi
je trouvais ça génial je trouve ça trop
qui d'une certaine façon leur la bonne
petite bourgeoisie provinciale
exactement voilà alors au début donc
effectivement vous avez 8 9 ans et c'est
fou parce que moi aussi j'ai un fils
kaka 8 en voilà et donc le mec s'appelle
didier il est projectionniste dans la
troupe de théâtre 40 et votre votre père
mes parents à beaune et vous raconter la
première fois vous dites il m'a fait la
chose sans nom circula on est vraiment
dans l'indicible c'est à dire que vous
au départ vous savez même pas ce qu'est
le sperme beaucoup et qu'il vous pisse
dessus donc non mais c'est foutu d'un
chat c'est à dire que vous ne mangez pas
donné de détails trop scabreux parce
qu'effectivement on est là pour ça pour
le lait c'est vrai que vous n'y
connaissez rien quand il commande non
mais pour pour le dire pour le dire
crûment c'est vrai que il me prend la
main il me la met sur sa [ __ ] et je sens
un truc mouiller je me dis mais [ __ ]
il a pissé c'est horrible c'est vraiment
dégueulasse
enfin bon et et
et ça prouve combien j'étais petit quoi
combien j'étais passé ce qui est
terrible en fait dans cette histoire
c'est que le plaisir que vous prenez pas
ce que vous prenez du plaisir vous êtes
bien sûr le premier à l'écrire aussi
clairement vous prenez du plaisir et ce
plaisir génère chez vous une certaine
culpabilité parce que vous dites
finalement je prends du plaisir donc
vous avez un tour de ça moi c'est ce que
tu as éviter cette culpabilité vous
amène à ne pas en parler autour de vous
ni à votre terne et votre meilleur oui
et puis alors il ya la culpabilité et
puis elle fait aussi que pour moi tous
les adultes sont un peu complice sabir
ils sont tous henri sama dubaï
c'est un ami de mes parents ils
travaillent tous ensemble et c'est donc
à qui je vais aller en parler
ouais à personne je vais pas en parler à
mes copains de l'école je vais pas en
parler non plus aux adultes puisque les
adultes sont tous ensemble donc ils sont
plus au courant
les [ __ ] ouais c'est ça alors vos
parents sont divorcés lui évidemment il
en profite pour s'immiscer comme ça
auprès des enfants et ce qui est
terrible quand on lit le bouquin c'est
qu'on se rend compte que vos parents
sont presque soulagé parce que c'est
vrai c'est une époque très edonys très
individualiste très égotiste où on se
dit finalement mois ci s'occupe des
mômes tant mieux dans vos parents bon ça
vaut rien d'abord et ensuite ils sont
pas mécontents que ce gala vous prennent
en charge
non parce qu'il avait des tas d'autres
choses à faire mon père était dans une
sorte de vertige incroyable il venait de
fonder sa troupe sa troupe avait un
théâtre national d'un seul coup de
données par le ministère de la culture
il avait plein d'argent il pouvait
monter tout ce qu'ils voulaient
britannicus malaise et cetera donc lui
il était parti dans son truc de théâtre
subventionné
et comment on dit délocalisé en fin de 2
de théâtre et puis ma mère elle l'avait
ses amants il fallait qu'elle refasse sa
vie et c'est votre mère elle était très
fière votre mère ce qu'elle est mais
sait séduire
donc effectivement elle avait toujours
des prix aussi faire le porc au caramel
voilà alors avec ce didier bas vous
habitez vous vivez chez lui lâche est
une maison pour vous une telle maison là
et vous vivez comme une espèce de petit
couple toujours bas 9 en juin 2009 à 14
voilà 14 ans nous étions en couple ouais
ouais
et ça c'est une photo qui a été fait par
le fameux dj derrière vous et des photos
à la main c'est un bon photographe qui
est une femme aurait alors il en a fait
d'autres qui sont un peu plus suggests
illicit ouais mais que vous n'avez pas
évidemment mais c'est déjà très gonflé
me mettre une photo nue en couverture
alors vos parents remarquent rien mais
en fait dans la ville on remarque c'est
à dire comme vous avez les cheveux longs
un peu de temps aux aînés vous avez des
pantalons pattes d'eph vous avez des
chemises indienne on vous traite de [ __ ]
dans la ville en dire mais c'est le [ __ ]
mais vous vivez ça vous supporter ça bah
ouais je suis pour tout ça et en même
temps ce qui est terrible c'est que en
même temps c'était vrai ouais
en même temps c'était vrai quoi que je
me dis 20 oui ces mecs là ils écoutent
sardou il écoute johnny hallyday
moi j'écoute frank zappa et david bowie
et je suis pas je suis pas que me quoi
il y avait un sentiment aussi la fin peu
à l'écart d'être mieux que les autres
d'une certaine façon d'être à la fois
mieux mais pas du tout avec les autres
c'était c'était super flippant
c'est à dire que j'avais deux copains
pour tous en tout et pour tout j'avais
deux copains et donc mes deux copains 30
ans et ce n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec moi parce qu'il préférait la
maladie d'amour à deux mains fines man
de frank zappa donc
il comprenait pas pourquoi moi
j'écoutais cette espèce de musique
bizarre hein
ouais ouais enfin bon il faut lire le
bouquin je veux pas en dire beaucoup
plus c'est très bien écrit à cette idée
que vous avez un certain moment de
mettre des phrases entre parenthèses et
en italique et et on comprend que c'est
peut-être ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
en tous les cas c'est rep si un jour
vous découvrez que c'est vous qui le
tenait ouais
et là c'est important des conduits vous
aime qu'il est qu'il a besoin de vous
beaucoup plus que ce que vous avez
besoin de lui et vous finirez par le
quitter mais quand vous le quittez vous
êtes tellement détruit peu à part dans
cet amour bizarre que vous sombrez dans
le lsd dans l'héroïne
bah non un nom à 15 ans à 15 ans ouais
non à 15 ans à 15 ans effectivement je
prends pour la première fois de
l'hérault du lsd plein plein de drogue
très différente etc
et je trouve ça super bon parce que
parce que ça me fait partie
je dirais pas qu aujourd'hui devant tout
le monde que c'est super bon mais pour
pour moi ça a été une espèce de oued de
libération en même temps je ne le
recommande à personne
sans la drogue c'est au début on en
prend pour être bien qu'ils apprendront
pas bien attendons concours pas être mal
et puis après on est très mal on connaît
l'histoire mon cher ami voilà alors là
vous vous demandez effectivement est ce
que vous êtes pédophile parce que
souvent les pédophiles réplique presque
1 subie ce qui était le cas d'ailleurs
de didier qui un jour vous amène sur les
lieux de son enfance et vous découvrez
qu'en fait il a été violentée étant
enfant vit peut-être que je suis
pédophiles peut-être que je vais refaire
les mêmes choses à des jeunes enfants
vous tenez vous vous demandez vous êtes
homo vous dit peut-être que je suis
homosexuel après toutes ces expériences
et vous vous rendez compte que
finalement non vous n'êtes pas
homosexuel vous rendez compte que vous
aimez les filles et je voudrais vous
êtes mariés
père de famille vous êtes deux filles et
comme vous dites vous n'arrivez pas à
leur donner un bain parce que parce que
ça vous revient à quoi voilà oui c'est
impossible je ne peux pas toucher le
corps des enfants ccc pour moi c'est
trop quoi dans un bénéfice est
impossible alors quand vous êtes dans la
drogue un jour votre père vient vous
engueuler en lisant pourquoi tu prend de
la drogue et vous dites m'enfin si tu
commences tu es occupé de moi et il vous
dira compte voulu raconter vous le
raconter à votre père est effectivement
il dit
j'ai l'impression de t'avoir abandonné
et l'a donc votre père vous lui dites
mais votre mère en fait il ya très peu
de temps qu'elle sait l'histoire ya deux
mois qu'elle sait l'histoire voit il ya
deux mois qu'elle sait l'histoire mais
elle a été elle était furieuse elle est
vraiment tombé par terre à ce mois là
elle a appelé ce mec
didier ouais ce jeu en lui disant aux
faits mois des aveux et cetera je veux
des aveux écrits et c est donc ce mec
m'a appelé à chez moi et donc il a eu ma
femme etc
enfin bon et c'est vrai que lui
se fait passer pour le bon samaritain il
a un bac vous d'en faire et où il est il
et ça c'est un mec assez extraordinaire
non il n'y pas non non il n'y rien mais
en même temps il veut pas il veut pas
aller en justice quoi je le comprends et
vous voulez y aller en justice où je
crois que c'est prescrit jeu il est
toujours dans l'entourage de votre père
votre père sait où il est
non c'est mon père sait où il est mais
ça y est il est plus dans toi je mon
père mais on a été longtemps
trente ans après donc vous arrivez enfin
dénoncée en comprendre elle a lu pour
vous en arriviez là aujourd'hui
pourquoi ne pas lui refait de procès
parce que pendant trente ans j'ai caché
tout ça sous un mouchoir jusqu'à temps
que je me retrouve à sainte anne où il
est fou et
où là je me suis dit bon mais tu peux
plus tu peux plus tu peux plus t'en
empêcher de de masquer quoi c'est pas
mon histoire
question vous avez fait libre pour
échapper à sainte-anne grosso modo qua
non mais disons la chose
ouais ouais ouais ouais quasiment voilà
je me suis retrouvé à 100 tonnes
plusieurs fois et donc maintenant c'est
stop quoi je veux je veux plus retourner
j'aime mes envies de ces rigolos une
fois de voir les fous regarder la télé
puis atténuer leur parle et où enfin bon
là c'est marrant mais deux fois trois
fois on stoppe quoi et là vous pensez
que c'est lille va vous sortir de ça
pour toujours c'est là que vous avez
enfermé simple cercueil de mouret même
si c'est un petit un petit cercueil
écrit avec des mots à l'intérieur et
puis maintenant la pêche et les jeter
dehors et puis le lit qui veut quoi
ouais à vos enfants quand ils liront les
bases et super g j'ai vraiment du mal à
leur expliquer ce que c'est parce qu'ils
y voient le livre alors ils voient la
couverture est plus lisse mais c'est toi
ouais c'est moi et
mais ça raconte quoi c'est une histoire
incroyable jean l'île au trésor
non non non c'est je vais t'expliquer
donc je dois leur expliquer demain
ouais ouais demain j'ai promis dur dans
tout un truc il faut continuer imaginez
que qui vous regarde là didier là vous
auriez quoi lui dire saga votre caméra
ben cache toi
ouais un cache toi arrête un casse toi
le plus possible donc arrête quoi et
qu'il a continué à prévost bah ouais
mais il avait déjà dragué des copains à
vous qui avez refusé un oui ouais ouais
ouais ouais non mais t'es pas
c'était pas un amour fidèle un an + wii
en plus obligé le dénoncer à la police
et quelque chose comme ça obligé non
mais je reste voilà où son numéro de
téléphone - l'autre où son nom vient
peut-être aller il s'appelle didier non
je peux pas mais
mais non j'ai j'ai pas envie de le
dénoncer j'ai un procès ça m'aurait bien
fait plaisir un certain moment mais
maintenant ça y est j'ai écrit ce
bouquin ccc ce qui pour moi et c c'est
pour moi une forme de une forme de
procès et c'est plus que ça c'est
vraiment plus que ça ouais voilà en tous
les cas ça arrive que je vous conseille
très très difficile à lire mais qui est
bien écrit et qui est très littéraire
surtout ouais mais en fait votre entrée
en littérature aussi
ouais c'est bien ouais vous c'est vrai
moi perso je trouve qu'il s'en sort pas
mal quand même il avait l'air plutôt que
dans ses mains se trouve c'est pas vu
avant mais vous avez l'air bien non ça
va mieux ça va mieux
qu'à 12 ans bravo merci christophe tison
il m'aidait c'est chez grasset et là
messieurs
kiev 10 ans
et maintenant j'accueille charles
berling
ensemble berlim là vous arrivez vous
arrivez du théâtre des amandiers à
nanterre où depuis le 15 janvier
jusqu'au 15 février
vous êtes hamlet dans une mise en scène
de patrice caurier et de moshe leiser
vous vous sortez la de quatre heures de
cm1 voilà charles tu proviens question
tu es passé par ou l'a86 bcct libre
c'est elie parce que là vous arrive et
nous on est là bon complètement des
genres ici la neige parti l'unc au
cordeau et dont vous arrivez vous
arrivez de quatre heures sur scène vous
est donné à fond ont été abaissés
intrigue performance extraordinaire ce
qui fait ses choix d'aller à nanterre
alors vous l'avez vous l'avez voulu vous
l'avez eu votre votre hamlet parce que
ça fait quatre ans que vous racontez
dans toutes les interviews gelé je veux
faire un bled je veux faire hamlet je
vais faire à mettre donc ça y est la wii
maintenant je paye non mais oui tout à
fait oui parce que oui j'avais enfin non
si j'avais très envie de le faire depuis
longtemps et puis moshe leiser et
patrice caurier sont des metteurs en
scène que j'aime beaucoup qui font de
l'opéra souvent beaucoup à l'étranger
mais que je suis leur travail et donc il
ya quatre ans s'est dit on va le faire
ensemble et on a volé de l'est ouais bon
là on a réuni des très bons acteurs de
théâtre comme christiane cohendy drive
une ligne marc bodnar c'est une
coproduction avec le québec aussi à le
théâtre du nouveau monde qui est dans le
coup c'est la traduction de qui excusez
moi parce que je me sers des princes
jean michel ballarin voilà sur
extraordinaire les gens sortent et 10
mais c'est pas vrai vous avez trafiqué
le texte c'est mot pour mot le texte de
shakespeare mais la traduction de jean
michel déprats et est belle parce que
voilà la bonne question d'ambiance de 18
si tu savais ouais libération qui était
témoin encore gelé à libération
libération qui est un journal pas
toujours facile dit charles berling se
donne au personnage de façon radicale
est totale il invente
il construit il fait vibrer voilà donc
c'est le seul papier que j'ai vu sur la
pièce en tous les cas pour le moment une
attitude hautement tous les cas oui
celui-là était extrêmement positif il ya
un truc qui n'aiment pas libération
c'est le décor ils parlaient pas et d'or
parce que l'idéal de leader alors que
c'est bien je sais pourquoi les décors
c'est pour donner le côté comique de
shakespeare j'imagine oui parce que
souvent je veux shakespeare et en
particulier à melay tendance avec un
regard comme ça c'est romantique ça soit
héros à ces protestants comme ça au fond
de la salle qui décide qui déverse une
belle pensée
nous on pense qu'aujourd'hui pour faire
cette pièce nous touche parce qu'elle
nous paraît vraiment ancré dans 20 dans
ce qu'on vit est donc le décor est moche
parce qu'on ne sait pas qu'il est moche
c'est qu'il est il ne veut pas être
bourg vient pas de vous n'avez pas de
bon goût bourgeois d'aujourd'hui enfin
veut que le ca soit une idée de dames
l'aide qu'ils soient réussies joly est
ou non on a dit nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ce qu'on ressent avec
cette place et et hamlet il faut bien
regarder que quand ils arrivent au début
de la pièce c'est vrai que ça va pas
fort mais quand il s'en va c'est encore
plus terribles justement bordel encore
tout est raté
que plus j'adore dieu on peut dire
d'hamlet que plus il cherche à agir plus
il fout la merde ce qu'est ce qui est
trés ce qui est très proche d'un héros
moderne justement mais c'est exactement
ce qui se passe pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui tout individu se disent même
les plus lucides pascal monette est très
intelligent très lucide mais les plus
lucides et se disent bon mais la
lucidité aujourd'hui ne sert plus à rien
c'est à dire que tout feu tout voir on
va tous au cas où on a répété pendant la
canicule cet été à nanterre il faisait
40 degrés il y avait une impression
comme ça avec cette canicule de côté aux
primaires de l'année prochaine c'est
encore pire
tiens donc ça va très bien avec la pièce
et ça nous a ça nous a donné l'élan est
parti à new york quand l'accès a été
alors là complètement le oui parce que
new york est une ville qui deviennent de
plus en plus folles enfin plus quand on
vient de paris les petits provinciaux
comme donc on essaie tout d'un coup
c'est hallucinant donc donc cette
débauche de 2,2 de choses d'objets de
sens c'est exactement ce qui traverse la
pièce est ce qu'ils traversent
hamlet qui ne peut se fier à personne
qui ne sait pas qui croire qu'ils ne
sais pas s'il a vu trop beau trop
profondément moderne
oui je crois mais vraiment en tout cas
moi je me retrouve totalement je crois
que rien déroule enfin vraiment même
fabrice et pour les enfin aujourd'hui
c'est en tout cas le rôle le plus fort
que j'ai jamais pu faire la vie ça va
par sa non la vie ça va très bien je
vous ai croisé l'autre jour vous m'avez
pas vu un seul agent m'avait près mais
je ne vis plus en ce moment très mal
j'ai croisé l'autre jour avec j'ai
croisé avec vos enfants à saint germain
des prés le faisait avec un un garçon
une fille non c'est pas ma fille
il maintient ses images jeunes fiancés
mais les très jeunes alors que sun je
sais pas où l'aide s'est coupé arriver à
garder
alors on ne joue pas à me l'aide par
hasard on va faire connaissance avec le
côté obscur de charles berling interview
côté obscur
[Musique]
ciao que tu es obscures puisque nico
leurs amis des fleurs là est ce que vous
avez déjà souhaiter la mort de quelqu'un
oui mais comme hamlet je les ai jamais
pu tuer mais ça m'est arrivé oui est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait l'amour en
nombre impair bah oui oui ouais avec 2
mai coup de fil ou non vous savez
beaucoup d'expérience
donc ça peut être deux mecs je vais
donner tout ce que vous voulez à
nanterre il s'en passe
est ce que vous pourriez signé pas vous
est ce que vous pourriez vous pas women
68 morts
est-ce que vous pourriez s'ensuit
merci
est ce que est ce que vous pourriez
signé un pacte avec tf1 un pacte avec cf
un grand partenaire olympia snowe ne
prend même pas la question
vous en voyez beaucoup vous dites aux
bourgeois passer des bourgeois qui
dirige la télé et finalement le mépris
qu'ils ont pour les classes populaires
sert de faire de la télé de merde alors
qu'eux ils savent qu'ils font de la
merde quoi non j'ai vision très cultivée
de savoir qu'ils font cela je crois que
certains qui font de la télé vraiment de
merde deux ont des responsabilités voilà
c'est ce que je dis ça j'en suis sûr et
je dis que ce qui va nous arriver dans
la gueule parce qu'à un moment donné
quand on commence à [ __ ] en l'air la
culture à [ __ ] en l'air l'intelligence
et la pensée des gens on se retrouve
avec des gens qui ne pense plus qu'à une
chose c'est prendre une kalachnikov et
vous tirer dessus si c'est ça qu'ils
veulent et benjamin était responsable et
certainement pas là bas si est-ce que
vous avez déjà été dépendant d'une
drogue oui laquelle
la cigarette c'est fini la wii c'est
courageux dit non depuis cran mais les
wings 5 ans c'était comme mon père parce
que là il m'a dit à 40 ans il faut
arrêter médecin votre nom ouais il m'a
dit après la courbe et le monde peut
dire ça comme ça et à 45 pour crever
donc j'ai envie de vivre
est-ce que vous avez déjà baiser la
femme d'un ami charles certainement mais
enfin je dis non est-ce que vous
regardez on est toujours un côté obscur
est ce que vous regardez les
documentaires sur les poulpes ce qui
serait beau mais ça peut arriver
cette attention c'est un signe ça
faisait quand on commence avec
documentaire sur les poulpes enfin je
les chercheurs savent c'est que vous
cherchez pas à vous si vous en voyez un
peu le regarder mais je n'ai pas acheté
des cassettes quoi je veux dire
non mais il ya des gens pensent que ça
fait bien contrôler c'est vrai le mode
explique moi c'est quoi le problème
il parait quand on regarde documentaire
sur les poulpes c'est un signe de
dérangement mais doit on dérange moins
de quoi est ce que moi j'ai mon psy chic
pas d'accord mais il sait que les
poulpes que lui pour tu regardes les
poules c'est autre chose les méduses et
les poules donc vous avez déjà regardé
documentaire sur les poulpes
oui mais enfin le hip hop j'ai toute une
collection coup je n'ai pas fait exprès
est-ce que vous avez déjà imaginer votre
intervilles peuvent ils alors oui ça
m'est arrivé une fois parce que j'ai eu
un accident de plongée et sur la
remontée
je pensais que j'allais pas fini par
monter voyez le haut je me suis dit j'y
arriverai pas j'y arriverai pas et là
j'ai vu en remontant j'ai vu mais j'ai
vu tout quoi les gens qui font emmerdes
il est mort qu'on voit ça on voit tout
ce qui se passe après on est ému même
mais enfin en même temps je n'y arrivais
tu es toujours dans ton m
il est toujours dans son rêve et il est
aux amandiers noram lettre merci
[Musique]
et maintenant pajot blind test
s'asseoir en platine j'accueille jean
claude thin nasa
[Musique]
il ya vincent mais venez mes amis
vachon la voilà voilà attention jean
goudalé
[Musique]
voilà donc un point pour l'équipe de
michael youn bravo
[Applaudissements]
trois fois dans votre émission thierry
vincent a gagné deux fois je sais tout
seul toit
[Musique]
attention jeu god
merci
[Musique]
moi
c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
percy sledge bravo pour l'équipe de big
n
attention jean claude tu es prêt
attention à toi
[Musique]
voilà donc là alors là c'est un point
bravo benjamin morgaine dont j'ai bien
connu la mer tu sais qu merci exonhit la
mère quand elle dirigeait le jardin à
lampard non sa mère déjà dans sa mère
dirigez de chardons des votes une star
sa mère alice morgan non mais c'est vrai
a dit ciaran c'est une star mais oui
elle danse elle faisait le jardin des
modes qui était un journal culte de cul
par de culte c'est toi tu vois c'est
nickel
la maison de consommation genre connaît
ça na waie
ça m'énerve une affaire de principe
et là c'est dur mais c'est je pense que
laurent baffie peut trouver celle là
attention jean claude
tu
jean manteau
avant ou bravo bravo benjamin roger
glover du groupe deep purple ou et la
milice beaucoup de pas avoir donné cette
réponse parce que c'est un standard et
occuper très bien en dessin animé là tu
vois on avait trop de points d'avancé
sur ce cd tout cas on est à 4 2 au nac
est de sartène c'est toujours de vente
est toujours devant attention c'est très
très très serré attention jean-claude
[Musique]
replay rigueur
attention ribes les blues
[Musique]
je vois ces deux égale à celle des
crises pourquoi nous aimerions que la
jeunesse est un vieux manteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle image on continue de plus en plus
difficile jean claude
[Musique]
bravo donc on est six mots l'équipe de
michael youn et ouais ouais
en tous les cas attend l'équipe de
mickey mais c'est ainsi moi j'ai une
culture moi dans mon enfance je faisais
pas du tout et ouais c'est zoli du recul
à
c
voilà l'or par équipe chez l'équipe de
michael youn qui gagne chaque point
[Musique]
et l'équipe du na li nina deux points
mais maintenant mais maintenant notre y
passent chaque piscine à sabrina
victoire au moins c'est chacun pour sa
gueule chérie vous êtes servis mais
réalisme mais pourquoi cellule presse
que la vie est injuste et non mais si
mais si
attention là maintenant il ya 3 il ya le
banco le super banco le méga banco
qui va remporter ce blind terre on
commence avec le banco jean-claude s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
m
sheikh jarrah
[Musique]
chaque oreille
attention mais thiery oui mais mais ne
me dites pas que ça s'arrête là mais non
via le superbe robe grenat
mais la vie est injuste vincent
attention mais je sais pas parce que je
travaille un petit peu allons-y au gpl
je connaisse dans la chaîne il se suit
estropiés benjamin biolay
je suis
[Musique]
tu paies pour votre santé thierry javier
une paillette dans l'oeil
nous étions inquiets et benjamins de la
shdm en profitant de la moder jamais la
non objection objections nous demander
de remettre la balle
non non non elle est soit sport ce que
tu veux rassurer de la famille tout va
bien mais ça va ça va j'ai un truc dans
l'ain mes chiens de ré le coup jusqu'à
la fin de l'émission maintenant donc
alain chabat a marqué donc le banco
benjamin biolay le super banco qui va
gagner le méga banco vous le saurez
après ça
les aider
à l'aller
oh
je dis oui
[Musique]
on ressent
voilà donc laurent c'était tout le monde
en parle
c'était tout le monde en parle voilà
c'est terminé c'était moi aussi mais on
s'est bien marré
on s'est bien marré c'était super merci
à toi oui oui eh ouais c'était sûrement
pas
carmen ben laden le voile déchirée chez
michel lafon
le single s'appelle comme des connards
alain chabat jean paul rouve pour le
film à rien alors jamais avec un chabal
jean paul rouve maurice barthélémy
marina foïs
pioche
françois martin laval pascal vincent ça
sort le 28 janvier mesdames messieurs je
making up en papier dans le chabab et on
va les voir aux éditions les arènes les
peluches les années
avec la femme au foot
le football comme à toulouse michaël
youn vincent desagnat et benjamin
morgaine les 11 commandements par
françois de saint gobain chariot alias
les real de madrid avec michaël youn
vincent desagnat et benjamin morgaine et
dieudonné
ça sort le 4 février
monsieur
beaucourt canada tirait droite merci ma
nutrition
notre 6 4 sans jamais violé merci
benjamin jamais album s'appelle ligety
oui mais aujourd'hui
segal de feuilles mesdames messieurs
christophe qu'ils ont gelé un bouquin
que je vous conseille s'appelle tu
m'aimais chez grasset charles berling a
fait avec charles berling gabriel arcand
isabelle blais
m
selon terra matière
emma vôtre
[Musique]
agent green days l'album s'appelle
compilation barfly volume 5
reporter sans frontières l union pour la
liberté de la presse
au prix de 8 euros beau jeu
tant prisé dans le monde voilà c'était
tout le monde en parle
je vous donne rendez vous
et malgré vous ces limitations
[Musique]
lamy
oh
[Musique]
on va à cannes
non
[Musique]
on va
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu